Started the recording,
started to broadcast.
What the Fuck Ladies and gentlemen.
See it doesn't show that it started but
I know it has.
I know,
but you got to like refresh it and shit.
He usually takes a couple of seconds.
That will do it.
It's bullshit son.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's me.
There you go.
Every time we do this,
I could have sworn I muted it this time.
You know when you do it by yourself,
you don't do it.
You catch yourself.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm going to distract you.
You do not.
No,
no,
no.
Don't make me make fun of you.
You stop.
Alright.
This mother fucker and his God damn
ipad.
Fucking love it.
Listen,
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's a little gay but if it's good
enough for the Romans,
that's good enough for the Greeks.
Look at you.
I got an ipad even though I said I
wasn't going to get one for you to get
one.
Like walked by,
said you guys got in them bitches.
St Guys said yes.
And I said okay,
let's go first day.
It's kind of interesting.
You know,
what I am interested in is what's going
gonna happen with these things,
like what are these things eventually
gonna,
eventually these things are going to be
able to control your house and Shit.
You know,
you could already do that.
And if the dragon naturally speaking,
is any good on this.
Do you know it?
This.
It's alright.
It's alright if you have a headphone
microphone thing plugged in to it.
I tried to do it like in a loud room in
it.
Well I got to write a book now and uh,
I just signed a deal.
So it's fucking official.
I'm in the middle of writing this thing
and I'm thinking,
God damn,
it takes a long time to write shit.
It might be easier to just talk it out,
but I don't think that stuff is any
good.
Now.
Some of the people told me that I'm a
voice recognition software is really
good on pcs,
but I'm not quite there on the Mac yet.
Have you heard of?
I didn't miss that because one of the
best ones on the PC is dragon naturally
speaking.
So it's the same technologies the same.
Everything's the same,
so there shouldn't be a difference,
but it's not the same version because
it's a unix based for the Mac operating
system.
Ryan is totally different.
It's like a different version.
It's the same programming language.
It's just,
it's,
I mean it's,
you know,
it's like a xbox and ps three.
I mean it's the same tech.
The programming is the same.
It's just two different ways.
Is that true?
Ladies and gentlemen,
did it maybe you wizards out there and
know whether or not he's speaking the
truth because,
uh,
I believe Brian,
but I also believe that Brian did not
know the answer.
Well,
it's just like I barely used dragon so I
could be wrong.
I'm not a huge dragon nerd,
but to me it makes sense that if a
company makes that kind of software,
it would be the same on pc and Mac and
might have to get there a different way,
but the actual brains of the software
would be the same.
The same program.
There's something about actually writing
things too.
That's better than speaking it and
writing it because like when I write
something,
if I write a blog,
I don't type that fast,
so if I'm writing something,
each word that I'm thinking about,
I'm writing really dwelling on it.
The other words that come
after it now,
that's why one of the things people are
always really impressed about is the
ability to speak without stammering and
that have something to say.
I mean that's the reason why Obama got
elected really is because not just
because he's black,
but because he's black and he's just
really good speaker,
you know,
he's really good at talking and there is
an art form to that.
It's a management of your,
the ability to recognize like what
you're gonna say next and the inflection
you're gonna use and preparation and all
that shit.
It's,
it's,
uh,
there's an art to it,
but,
you know,
it's more interesting.
Usually when I read things that people
wrote and they actually wrote it,
they sat down and they really thought
about how this is going to be absorbed.
You know,
there's a craft,
there's a craft to both,
but there's a real craft to writing,
you know,
actual writing itself.
I really appreciate it when I read good
writers,
don't you?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I don't read that much,
but the few books that I choose,
I pick out certain things I want to read
this.
I read all day on the Internet when it
comes to a book.
I'm like,
all right,
I've read so much today I don't need to
read anymore,
you know,
type thing.
So I've actually been reading less books
ever since the Internet kind of grabbed,
grabbed me,
I've noticed.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Last good book I read was a book called
early bird.
Highly recommended though.
It's about a guy that used to write for,
I think letterman and he retired.
This is real,
a real guy.
And he retired and he went to Florida
and lived in a retirement home and he
documented his life inside a retirement
home being retired at the age of 35.
It was one of the funniest books.
It's weird how they,
the retirement village is like high
school.
You know,
there's like the popular old people and
they have like their cliques and stuff
like that and it's so weird.
You kind of go back to that,
that old school thing.
That's hilarious.
Early bird.
Yeah.
People are like that man.
They like that no matter what,
they're like that if they're 80,
they're like that.
If there were 180 for,
you know,
we're monkeys,
man.
We have a whole bunch of instincts that
we follow that uh,
really are directly attributable to our
time in the jungle,
you know?
I mean,
that's what I've said about human
beings,
that there's something fucked up about
us where we need.
You're distracting the shit out of me
with that thing,
son.
Let's not be fucking browsing online.
Yeah.
Tom was actually seeing if we could get
our live show on the IPAD.
Oh,
doing it live.
So watched new fucking move.
Know.
Don't sit behind me because then I can't
talk to you.
I'm going to turn like this.
My neck hurts from Jujitsu.
Hey,
you fucking me.
Forgotten what we were talking about.
Uh,
yeah,
me too.
Damn.
Fucking stoners.
Uh,
we were talking about talking and
writing and the last guy who got me into
writing or reading and writing really,
but,
uh,
I read the great shark hunt,
the hunter s Thompson Book.
It's kind of a compilation book of all
of his,
uh,
his stories.
Fuck,
that dude could,
right?
That dude had some really interesting
writing like guy you excited to read
more about it,
you know,
and it's kind of like this weird blend
of fiction and nonfiction.
That's one of the things that was so
cool about hunter's writing is like this
guy was just crazy.
It was making all kinds of crazy shit up
about like Las Vegas and campaigns and
dudes being on drugs.
You know,
when Ed Muskie was running for
president,
Hunter Thompson just started printing in
rolling stone magazine every week that
it was like widely known.
This guy had an ebook again,
addiction and that he was bringing in
Brazilian doctors.
Like nobody ever done that before.
Nobody's ever done like real serious
coverage of like a political event and
just started adding nutty shit to it.
That totally wasn't real.
So literally this guy changed the
fucking course,
the election because that guy was like
one of the favorites and because hunters
writing about him having an evil game
addiction,
which is this crazy exotic drug from
Africa,
you know,
Hunter wrote this whole thing about it
and this guy literally fell apart on the
campaign trail.
People were heckling him and he's doing
these campaign speeches and just
crumpled,
just bring some crazy shit that this guy
wrote.
And when they asked him about it and he
goes,
uh,
well,
you,
you made up that stuff about,
you know,
ed muskie having an irrigator,
he goes,
well,
I didn't make it up.
I,
I didn't print.
I said it was a rumor and it goes in.
It was a rumor and I started in
Milwaukee.
It was crazy.
It was just.
But he got away with it and he was just
constantly on acid.
He was constantly doing masculine who's
constantly doing cocaine.
I mean,
he was constantly getting fucked up and
writing.
That's like Super Uber fucked up.
Is there a book or a movie that you
would recommend about all this?
Yeah,
well I didn't even get into him until I
watched the documentary Gonzo.
I'd like to move you fear and loathing
in Las Vegas and I'd seen him on talk
shows before.
I always knew that he was just kind of
crazy guy.
There was this older dude who was really
nutty,
like to shoot guns and it looked like,
you know,
your friend's Dad,
but he was fucking completely psychotic,
you know,
it was just this guy left over from the
sixties that somehow or another morphed
into this like super violent fucking
drug addled compound Chuckii.
That's what he used to call themselves.
You know,
I just added it to my netflix queue on
my ipad.
Yeah,
good job.
Good job.
See that?
Where it's very good documentary,
but it's a really well made too.
So it really gets you into how fucking
interesting this guy was.
And it brings me back to the same thing
that I always think of,
man,
I'm when you're really that good.
He's so good.
I always wonder how fucking crazy you
have to be to be really good.
You know,
like,
you know,
in almost everything like Michael
Jackson and fucking sports,
anybody like tiger woods,
you know,
look how crazy is.
I almost think that you have to be a
certain.
There's a certain amount of imbalanced
to you to be really the best at anything
to be.
Excellent.
Yeah.
Well that's why you're considered the
best.
Usually not in the same road as
everybody else.
You're on the side street,
you know,
you're a little different than everyone
else.
So that's the most successful people are
not just a common person in everything.
They do,
not just that.
What I'm saying is that the commitment
that's involved in order to get to the
highest levels of anything,
like you almost have to be completely
not knowing that I hit those Rpms,
you know,
it's like um,
with so many things,
especially when it comes to the working
world,
when it comes to like the world,
I could see a,
you know,
an argument for there's no,
there's never too much.
It's never too much art that you can
produce because you just producing
positive energy.
People that get addicted to success in
the business world.
And try to be like the number one guy in
I mean,
that's one of the main reasons why we
have all these problems today with
corporations or corporations are sort of
these consciousness list entities,
you know,
I mean now corporations basically are
allowed to,
uh,
they're,
they're judged as an individual.
You know,
corporations are a thing,
like they have rights and shit.
Like they can contribute to campaigns
now as much as they want.
They can do all kinds of crazy shit,
you know,
as,
as a corporation and get away with it
because they don't think of it as them,
as an individual doing it.
They think of it as well,
you know,
it's all business and we're part of
business.
Like they can do fucked up things in
overseas countries,
you know,
third world countries and they don't
even think that they're doing anything
bad because what they're doing is
they're just doing business and there's
just a bunch of people involved doing
it.
So no one person feels like total
responsibility for what's happening,
you know?
And that's,
that's like a,
that's like a real problem that we have.
And I think one of the real problems
that we have is related to people just
being super competitive,
you know,
that's the only reason why these fucking
super crazy billionaire dudes would keep
pushing forward,
you know,
at a certain point in time,
how much fucking money do you have to
have,
you know,
when you're one of those dudes that has
like 30,
$40,
billion dollars and you're still trying
to rape third world countries.
Like what the fuck is going on?
Like how much money do you need,
bitch,
you know,
that's a lot of goddamn money.
And what is that?
Why?
Why would they not be able to recognize
that there's something wrong there?
Well then they're crazy.
That's what it is to get at the highest
levels of anything.
Whether it's golf or whether it's
fucking,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is to get at the
highest levels of anything.
You got to be a little naughty man.
Whether it's sports,
whether it's singing or performing the
writing,
you know,
I think,
to really achieve those,
those,
those crazy great highs,
like you almost have to like lose your
connection to everybody else or lose
control of your connection.
You know,
it's weird because that's our high
watermark,
you know,
and we're always aspiring towards higher
and higher levels of performance in
everything we do.
Whether it's athletic or anything you
do,
you're always trying to do better than
you did before.
You know,
I mean that's like a human ethic that we
have and it's a very strange man because
there's never a point in time where we
ever stepped back and go,
you know,
hey,
this is,
this is good.
We're good right here.
Let's just,
let's concentrate our time right now.
Instead of making more money,
let's try to concentrate all our time
and trying to make things better for
each other.
You know,
let's kind of try to concentrate our
time and dealing with all these problems
that exist all over the world.
Instead of trying to fucking smash atoms
and create black holes.
Let's,
let's settle down.
You know,
and let's concentrate on some other shit
when we look at a surplus of money that
we have,
but they don't ever think like that.
All they think of as more and more and
more and more and more and more and more
like they're going to live forever and
those motherfuckers drop a heart attacks
left and right.
Those like ceos
of big corporation type dudes,
those motherfuckers die like crazy.
They die all the time.
Those guys are,
you know,
like Dick Cheney's at 150 fucking heart
attacks.
And one of the reasons is,
is because he's,
he's just such an evil cunt.
You know,
if you're that fucking evil,
you know you're going to have some
goddamn heart attack you,
you're doing some wicked shit.
You're creating so much bad energy and
you're pushing constantly,
constantly,
constantly.
You know,
what kind of balls do you have to have
to be the fucking CEO of a corporation
like Halliburton and then go from that
to being the vice president of the
United States and then go from that to
signing billion dollar agreements with
Halliburton.
We're billions.
Literally billions of dollars were lost,
like they don't know where it went.
Billions and corruption.
They have no idea where,
like all kinds of money went.
And the fact that that motherfucker
profited on it.
He had shares in Halliburton while he
was the fucking president.
I mean,
he got money from them while he was the
president or vice president.
What do you mean really?
Was the president really was the fucking
marionette supposedly remember the days
where he was always in the bunker.
Remember?
They would always,
they would always talk about Dick Cheney
been in the bunker and where's this
bunker?
These,
there's some Batman type shit,
you know,
what does he have?
What is the Dick Cheney bunker?
It's just probably like a golf club.
It's another nickname for a golf club.
He's at the bunker,
at the whorehouse dudes banging dudes,
you know,
that was the big secret of the fucking,
uh,
the,
the whole,
uh,
Bush White House was,
there was a lot of gay shit going on.
A lot of gay shit.
That guy,
Jeff Gannon,
who's a reporter for,
um,
the White House.
He was a White House embedded reporter.
And he would love the super softball
questions at President Bush,
like Mr Bush,
President Bush,
when or Mr President,
when are the Democrats just going to
come to reality?
When are they going to come to their
senses?
Do you think that's ever gonna Happen?
He would say shit like that.
And other reporters were like,
who is this motherfucker?
And so the other reporters started
investigating the student and they found
out that he had a fucking gay porn
website with him,
him with like,
you know,
like fucking bare chested and like a
towel over his cock and shit,
like super gay with dog tags on.
And it was gay porn geared towards guys
with military fetishes.
Yes.
What have you heard about that
typical guy?
Have you heard about that guy in the
news recently that tickled parties?
Uh,
with,
uh,
he worked off.
Same thing like he worked for the
government somehow or like the dude.
Does anyone know what I'm talking about?
The typical guy that had like ticklers
that would come over and they would all
have to tickle parties.
Well,
how about that fucking woman?
You can make the Madam,
how about that woman who was the madam
for that big fucking brothel in
Washington dc and this chick claims
she's got the fucking ends on everybody
in Washington.
All of these senators that use to
service all these different people and
then she commit suicide and she even
said she at her interviews,
if I commit suicide,
they did this to me.
I am not going to kill myself.
I'm happy.
I want to live.
It was fucking gone and the whole case
gone.
Dust in the wind,
dust in the wind would Jesse James did
you see?
Oh my goodness.
And that's what happens man.
People get fucking wacky about Jesse
James or tiger woods or whatever the
fuck it is this week in the news and
while all that's going on,
crime just left and right.
They're just stealing,
stealing money and fucking pitches and
killing bitches are going to fuck
bitches.
It's the congressmen Eric Massa that had
to tickle part.
Oh,
interesting Democrats,
Senator Democrat,
senator.
It was on the daily show.
He was on a daily show talking about it.
No,
I think they had it on the daily show.
That's where they talked about that.
So take a story.
New York Times,
somebody's twitter to look at.
Sweet.
Oh,
is that the the tweets or the chat
thing?
This is on twitter right now.
People responding to you on twitter,
so if you go to Joe's website,
Joe Rogan net,
click on webcams.
You can see the chat we're talking
about.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or you can go to my ustream page.
You can see the whole chat on the
extreme page.
What the hell is joe going on about
things?
She can't just tune in.
Halfway in the middle we're talking
about shit.
The way the human mind works,
man,
that there's an error and the way the
human mind works and that's the reason
why people are doing all this crazy shit
like trying to conquer the world and you
know,
and billionaires are fucking torturing
these third world countries and crushing
their resources and doing it all for
money.
They're.
The reason why is there's a,
there's an error and the human mind and
there's an error that causes us to never
have perspective.
We're always moving in a direction,
but we don't have a perspective like
nobody ever stops and very,
very few people stop and realize that a
certain point in time,
like I would rather live a,
an easy going really peaceful life and
make less money and have less bullshit
and less drama in my life and you know,
and just be happy all the time.
Then be this like super ambitious,
you know,
gotta go get it.
Typical American,
you know,
and that,
that's a problem in that fucking typical
American attitude is bullshit because
we're going to die.
We're fucking dying.
All of us.
There's just.
This is totally temporary.
So like the,
the one thing to do is to try to balance
it all out and have the most amount of
fun possible and the most amount of
positive time,
the most amount of positive energy
during the time that you have.
But then there's the keeping up with the
Joneses thing.
This trick that gets us thinking that
somehow or another,
like bigger houses and bigger cars or
bullshit is going to make you happy.
Some of the most miserable Fox that I've
ever met in my life were rich and
famous.
Okay.
The some of the most miserable fucking
human beings I've ever met.
Rich and famous and living in a
torturous existence.
You know,
like we were talking about.
Our friend on the way over here has got
the female problem.
You know,
this guy is a very
successful guy.
He's like,
been on television.
He's,
you know,
he's a,
he's a guy that people enjoy.
They go to see him.
Has Life is all I know.
It's fucking chaos and it's just,
it's,
it's.
So.
It's a few steps before murder.
Suicide,
right?
It is.
It's right there.
It's not going to murder suicides door.
You know,
if you got that phone call in the middle
of the night,
you wouldn't be that surprised you.
But God damn it.
Damn.
Should've done something else.
Yeah.
This is nothing you can do.
That's,
that's the cold hard facts.
There's nothing you can do.
At the end of the day,
these motherfuckers have to go home.
It's like you have to figure out what is
it that we're really doing here?
What is it,
and because they're so fucking many of
us,
I think that human beings have lost this
sense of community.
I think human beings are programmed to
be in tribes were programmed to be in
tribes of like 50 to 200 people or maybe
more,
but enough that you know everybody and
you know,
when we live alone,
we're fucking miserable.
Like that's why we don't trust hermits.
We don't trust people that go off into
the woods by themselves.
We look at this sketch,
you motherfucker,
he wants to be by himself.
You know,
we don't trust that shit because that's
not how you're supposed to be.
We're not programmed for that.
We're programmed to be in small groups
of people so that we worked together and
we protect each other and we support
each other.
But we're living in a group that's way
too big.
Were tricked into believing that the
were a part of some $300,
million strong group.
You know?
That's why like wars work,
you know the reason why wars work is
because we feel like,
well,
yeah,
we got to defend ourselves and we all
know we have this sort of sense of
loyalty,
defend ourselves,
but a certain port tenants like against
what?
Hold on a second,
whose we are $300 million fucking people
and we're defending ourselves against
what,
300 million other people from somewhere
else and we don't even know what is
going on.
Why are they really after us?
Like,
what's happening?
Well,
I'm getting this from you and I'm
connected to you somehow.
Who the fuck are you and why these
people mad at you.
Why are these fucking people in this
other country mad at you?
Why do they want to come over here and
kill me?
Because some shit you did.
What the fuck are we doing?
Until you know what we're doing
overseas?
You can't support it.
You can't be involved.
You know,
there's a video that was released that
you haven't seen yet that it was on Wiki
leaks where it shows this a Apache
helicopter shooting these hellfire
missiles into these people and they
weren't soldiers.
They were mistaken as soldiers and I
don't know us did it.
I watched it.
The US duty.
Yeah.
The 2007 and covered it up and then wiki
leaks got ahold of it.
Someone in the armed forces apparently
was a whistleblower and just thought
that this was a horrible situation and
needed to be corrected.
And these guys were like,
you know,
look,
I mean if they thought there were
insurgents,
I could see how they develop this
antagonistic attitude towards the enemy
because this guy's willing to.
They shot him up as one guy,
survivors.
I just pick up a weapon,
just pick up a weapon like he's asking
them to just pick up,
pick up a weapon so he could isom and
he's got these 30 and they've looked at
the,
they're the bad guy and this guy is out
there and he's in the shit and he's
trying to survive.
I mean that's the attitude you have to
have.
If you don't have that attitude and
you're in war,
you're going to get killed,
but what it shows you is like,
what the fuck are we doing there?
Like what?
What is?
What are we doing that our American
friends are people who live over here in
this country are subject to becoming
that guy are subject to being put in a
situation when they are shooting at
civilians accidentally and thinking
they're insurgents.
They have to live with these fucking
memories because someone told us that
we're supposed to be over there for some
fucking strange reason,
some fake weapons of mass destruction
and now some fucking democracy building
project.
You were surprised though.
An 18 year old made a debt bad decision.
That was an 18 year old pilots.
I know,
but half those people are so young that
it's retarded and I didn't get smart and
I'm smart with like a z until you may
25,
27.
I would probably say I started actually
doing making better decisions.
Not fucking crazy shit.
No,
listen,
no,
no doubt about it.
I was retarded when I was 18 and if I
was 18 and I was in war,
I would be doing the exact same shit.
I was hyper-aggressive extra violent and
ready to ready to do stupid shit.
You know when you're an 18 year old man
and you're around a bunch of people who
tell you you are supposed to be doing
stupid shit,
you're supposed to be violent.
You're supposed to be attacking.
You're supposed to be a killer.
I mean,
man,
you,
you could program the shit out of us,
man,
if you,
if you're a fucking angry 18 year old
kid,
you know who has a,
a,
a need to belong to something and this
need to belong takes you to another
country and all of a sudden you're,
you know,
you're in Afghanistan,
you're fighting for America.
You feel like,
you know,
you're representing some real shit.
And then someone's fucking telling you,
you know,
this guy is telling you you're a goddamn
killer.
You know,
you know you.
I'm fucking proud of you boys.
You go out there and go get it.
You know,
like total,
full metal jacket style.
You know,
man and any of us could get sucked into
that.
I could've got sucked into it.
You could've got sucked into it.
We all could have,
but the idea that they're over there
protecting us,
like,
man,
we have to sit down and fucking talk
this through.
Like,
what are you talking about?
You know,
they're protecting us.
Like they're protecting our freedoms.
Look,
if they really were protecting our
freedoms,
what a noble thing.
If there really was some evil empire out
there like,
like the Nazis that were trying to
fucking take out Americans and there was
millions of them and they're storming
the beaches and taking over countries.
That's not what's happening.
Okay.
There's a bunch of fucking dudes living
in caves and we don't even have to
fucking go in with what we're doing now
that's most successful because he's
fucking drones.
These,
these aircrafts that are shooting around
total straight video game type Shit,
Shooting Hellfire missiles into
mountains and killing people.
I mean,
that's probably the best way to hunt
these fucking dudes anyway.
If there really are terrorists out
there,
like the whole thing is nuts and you
hear people like Michael Moore saying
that there's only a hundred Taliban or a
thousand Taliban.
He said,
living in Afghanistan,
it was 100 or thousand.
Neither one of them is nuts.
The fact that we got 30,000
troops over there,
I was like,
what do we just sent $30,000
more like,
what the fuck are we doing?
It's all so scary that we're putting our
trust into people that are known liars.
You know the idea of protecting America.
The idea of being a proud citizen is
standing up for your country.
That's all noble.
The real problem is who is giving the
Goddamn fucking orders?
People that totally cannot be trusted
across the board full of Shit at every
goddamn turn,
whether it's the Gulf of Tonkin,
whether it's a weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq or whatever the fuck
it may be.
You know,
and it's not just Republican,
it's Democrat,
it's this fucking crazy healthcare thing
and it's fucking crazy thing that's
going on with the bank.
Bail outs were all this money is just
flying around and there's no
accountability.
Nobody knows where the fuck it's going
and these executives that came from
these companies that got big fucking
bail out checks.
They're taking big bonus checks and
saying,
well,
if they don't get these bonuses,
they quit like,
fuck you.
What is happening?
This is a goddamn money grab.
Like how is this money grab going on?
The money grabs grown out because
they're all corrupt that Democrats and
Republicans,
they all owe favors to people that got
them in office and they suck Dick and
kiss ass and they let this bullshit pass
through.
So it's not just the Republicans.
It's not just the people who want war,
the military industrial complex,
it's fucking all of them.
It's all of them.
We live in a horribly corrupt system.
That is,
we're.
We're like sick.
We're like the human race is sick.
There's something wrong with the way we
think and behave and or it's right and
we think it's wrong to think that
because it doesn't know because it
doesn't have to be this way.
If you want total enjoyment for the
people that are participating in it,
it doesn't have to be this way and the
way it is right now,
it's this way because too many people
are passive and they're sitting back and
they're just allowing this life to keep
rolling forward in the same direction.
It's going in a certain direction for
sure,
but it doesn't have to be negative and
it doesn't have to fucking involve war.
It doesn't have to involve all the shit
that's going on in these other countries
were being tricked into thinking it does
it.
We're supposed to be getting past that
shit and we're supposed to be evolving
in a technological sense,
but we should be evolving socially too,
and we're not.
We're still socially the same way.
We're 30,
40,
50 years ago.
We're still doing the same dumb shit
where it's gigantic groups of people led
by a couple of leaders will attack
another gigantic group of people and a
bunch of fucking people that have
nothing to do with anything die and
someone is getting money from it all.
It's.
That's all it is.
It's all about resources.
Every fucking one that's ever been
fought ever there about resources and
it's just crazy that in 2010 we know the
real problem is we live too long.
You know,
right now we live to be 80,
9,100.
You live long enough to figure out.
It's all bullshit.
Back in the day when you were fighting
for the Roman empire,
you know you died a fucking plague when
you're 19.
You know what I'm saying?
If you live to be 30 you,
you,
you did a lot of shit.
You got a long ass life.
You know Jesus,
they killed him at 33.
If he was ever real,
you know what I mean?
Look at all the people that live back
then.
You know the holidays.
Motherfuckers live forever.
You know,
you,
you hear about some new lady in France,
it's just,
you know,
100 2,626
smoke cigarettes,
drank red wine,
but the one in 26,
it's incredible.
People live way low and you live if you
live past a certain point,
like you and I are very fortunate
because we're in the entertainment
industry so we don't have a specific job
that we have to do every morning like we
don't have to go to work and work on say
insurance cases all day stuff that we're
not interested in.
We're lucky that we get to create and
we're lucky that we get to do stuff that
we find interesting,
but it's all fun.
But for most people that's not the case.
And when,
when it's not the case and when your
whole day is filled with work and I've
been there before and you've been there
before,
you don't fucking think too much.
You don't figure too much out.
You know when you're working eight hours
a goddamn day plus and you try and get
some overtime,
man,
because you got extra bills and credit
card debt and shit.
You know,
when it gets to a certain point in time,
you know,
at the end of your day,
man,
you don't got time to contemplate the
universe or culture or you know,
why people behave the way they behave.
No,
you just fucking keep going.
You know,
life has got damn hard.
You just keep fucking going.
But you and I have way more time by
ourselves to think on our own than most
people.
So you get to a certain point in time
and you know what,
by the time 42,
by the time you're like 42,
like fuck man.
The whole hustle is so obvious and
stupid.
It's like the same hustle that would've
gotten me when I was 18.
I would've got them joined the army for
sure when I was 18 for when I'm 42.
It makes me angry because somebody my
age is doing this hustle on someone
who's 18,
you know,
not even my age older than me.
You know?
I mean,
it's like you motherfuckers should have
figured it out already.
You motherfuckers that are older than me
that are running the planet.
You should be delivering this message.
You should have figured this out.
You should know that we're,
we're living like retards,
that this is nonsensical,
that this is.
No,
this is not sustainable,
but we could live a sustainable life and
it doesn't involve going to countries
where you've never been in fucking up
people you've never met.
It doesn't involve that.
You know,
and this fucking argument like about our
boys.
Well,
you know,
what do you want our boys to die?
That's how they have to behave over
there.
That's stupid.
That's a stupid argument.
Yeah,
I know that that's how they have to
behave when they're at war.
A 100 percent,
but that's not the argument.
The argument,
this is,
this is nonsense.
They shouldn't fucking be there in the
first place.
It's not that they're not heroes.
It's not that they're not brave.
They are.
Absolutely.
You have to be.
I mean,
that's real fucking fighting.
That's real.
Live killing and fighting with tanks and
missiles and jets and shit.
That must be white knuckled.
Terrifying.
You didn't even like hurt locker,
did you?
Nope.
How come he didn't like hurt locker?
I thought it was boring as fuck.
You need to go to a doctor,
get your balls checked out.
That movie was.
We talked about this a million times.
I know it.
Did you gotta get your balls?
Sorry.
I'll tell you what sucks.
Clash of the titans.
Oh yeah,
that's stupid.
It was dumb.
It was so dumb.
I mean,
I like
the special effects are kind of bad ass.
The cracking was pretty dope when the
cracking comes out,
you're like,
God
thing is just like a made for TV movie.
Special effects.
Sucked ass.
I heard,
I kinda liked the Medusa,
you know,
the problem was there wasn't enough shit
going down,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't want to see it.
Do you see hot tub time machine?
Um,
no I haven't seen that or heard.
That was bad too.
But what is this gentleman saying?
I don't like to respond too much to
negative people that don't know what
he's saying.
Of course he's reading it.
All he cares about is his internet
reputation.
Not even listening.
Huh?
And then you're talking to me.
Some chick asked me a question on
twitter today.
It was one of the,
the,
it was one of the most ridiculous
questions that I've ever like heard
ever.
So I like,
look at this.
This chick says to me,
her name is Taurus spa or 12.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It's on my twitter feed.
She says,
Joe,
you can't seriously not believe in
evolution.
You don't believe in that God.
Listen,
listen,
listen how it's worded.
You can't seriously not believe.
Like I didn't even know what she was
asking.
I had lost it.
So I said saying,
if I can't not just,
that means I can write what the fuck.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
And then I'm saying that I said that.
I'm not saying I don't,
not,
I'm saying she don't know if I do or
don't.
Yeah,
it was like fucking do something about,
um,
twitter speak and uh,
something about,
uh,
tech speak that's making people really
retarded.
Yeah.
And it's so much better than curse of
man.
I just got a letter the other day in
cursive and it made me cry.
I will take.
No,
no.
You know,
cursive doesn't imply stupid to me.
When I read something in tech speak like
you are.
I go,
God damn it.
I do it.
When dudes do it,
it drives me nuts.
Yeah,
but my brain immediately skipped to and
understand what it was supposed to save
recursive.
I'm more like,
okay,
that's Z.
that's why.
Oh,
you apostrophe r e dot.
When you get a Goddamn text message from
me,
you're going to get a fucking
apostrophe.
You're going to get a U Apostrophe r,
e mold.
School's son.
I'm old school so I prefer a stick
shift.
There's just too much God damn traffic
in La,
but I really prefer to shift my own
fucking gears.
You know what I'm saying?
Do you like to shift your own gears?
A nine in la now?
Fuck.
Fucking nice fucking BMW or nine slash
11 turbo or some shit.
You want to sit down with automatics are
means manual.
I don't know.
My first sports car,
there's nothing like it so far.
I have a little BMW m three.
I love that thing,
but it's got the paddle shifters and the
paddle shifters are pretty dope and
traffic because you really can't shift
gears when you want and you really
control the engine,
but there's something about pressing
that foot clutch down.
Put Nat gearing,
click,
let the off hitting the gas at the same
time.
It's like you're in tune with the
machine,
man.
You're in tune with the machine.
I'm just pressing buttons.
I'm hitting the gas and pressing buttons
and it's fun.
I mean,
don't get me wrong.
The fucking car.
It's funny shit.
These little cars now they make like
little bmws.
They handle so good.
Then they're just like.
They figured it out now and there's a
crazy horse power war now,
so like regular cars that you buy are so
much more fast than they've ever been
before.
This BMT old BMW before this one had 333
horsepower.
This one has 420.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's as fast as my old nine slash 11
turbo.
That old porsche that I was to have.
That thing was stupid fast.
This thing is just as fast as that,
but handles way better.
Like the balance is like perfect.
It's like you feel like you can just
move it like it's not even real.
It's like the gold card or something.
You know?
It's incredible what they're doing now.
Those new,
like those new mustangs that the shelby,
the,
the.
What is the,
the,
the GT 500.
Those fucking things have 540 horsepower
man.
And never buy unnecessary.
Yes,
but fun as fuck.
That's fun as fuck dude.
If you had one of those Mustang's those
really fast one.
Boom Dude.
That does nothing for me anymore when I
was a kid.
Yes.
But nowadays I'm like,
no,
I want to live.
Okay.
What if you had a weekend car would,
if you had this and you had like a
Mustang gt,
$500 a weekend car,
you don't think that would be fun to
fucking.
Just,
just not safely.
I'm not talking about going down
residential roads 150 miles an hour,
but that merging onto the highway to 70.
Like that song,
you feel that fucking roar that va knows
fat four inch pipes.
Are you kidding me?
That's fun as fuck.
That is fun.
As far I guess I haven't done it in
awhile.
Yeah,
you haven't done it awhile.
If he did it,
did it.
Every now and then he realized that's
fun as fuck man.
There's a.
You know there is going to be a limit
though.
A certain point in time.
Like how fucking fast these things go.
The new nine slash 11 turbo is zero to
60 in three goddamn seconds.
Three seconds.
One,
two,
three 60 miles an hour.
That's insane.
You have stuck in texts from a girl and
shut that shit off.
Twenty percent battery.
Low faggot.
Knowledge me,
dude,
please.
There I did.
I acknowledged you.
Dude.
You're way behind.
Way Behind.
What are you talking about?
Thing?
It's too much.
Too many people.
Too much.
Have I ever seen the movie called
falling down with Michael Douglas.
His grades are good goddamn movie.
I love it.
And that's how you feel when you live in
La,
in La.
After awhile you're like,
no,
there's too many humans.
They did population density studies with
rats who had took rats.
They put them in a box and there was,
you know,
there's a certain population of rats and
they were cool with each other and then
they doubled it and they started getting
a little crazy and they tripled it and
when they got to like a high number with
a wrapper on top of each other,
rats developed mental illnesses just
like human beings do.
There's some would sit by themselves and
shake and just like face the corner.
I mean they literally,
the way human beings are is mirrored and
population density studies for all sorts
of animals.
So you know,
you take us and he put us in the same.
The reason why people yell at each other
on the highway.
That's craziness.
Why we get so angry and angry on the
highway with this because we grow on top
of each other.
Just eat each other's energy.
All Atlantic.
You're not supposed to live like that.
And so that movie,
that movie just resonates with
everybody.
I think when he just went fucking crazy.
When you live in at a place like La,
La has got 20 million people in it.
I mean that was the reason why I moved
to Colorado in the first place.
I wanted to get away from this heavy
vibration of all these people.
You know,
I don't think this is a healthy way to
live.
I don't think it's a healthy thing to be
like this many people.
To me,
I feel like I'm living in a game of
musical chairs.
Like one day some shit's going to go
down and I'm just going to have to go
further away,
you know?
I don't feel like I could stay here now.
Did you feel that earthquake the other
day?
No,
I didn't.
I didn't feel it either.
I was in the car either,
but it wasn't Mexican wave.
Our friend Duncan said that his
bookshelf was moving.
He said it felt like you were on a boat,
like you're waving.
That said,
our friend,
Duncan's done a lot of acid in his.
Well,
I heard from a few people.
Same thing,
same exact thing.
Wavy motions,
like three people told me,
well,
it was a pretty big one.
It was a seven point.
Oh,
six point six point nine or something
like that or something else in Baja
California and that's like Mexico.
Right?
Then there was Jesse Ventura lives,
I don't know.
It's fucking government and then 15
minutes later,
20 minutes later there was like a four
point three over north north of Los
Angeles.
The government try to fly with me.
That's bad.
Jesse Ventura impression.
That's great.
He said that the dude who lives in
Mexico,
half the year,
seven point two,
I think that's pretty cool.
Seven point two,
seven point eight.
Indonesia.
Two hours ago.
Is that true?
Okay.
I'm going to have to check that shit out
because that's ridiculous.
I might have to run and hide in the
basement and that Shit's real traffic.
Indonesia sir.
Let's move to North Carolina.
Yeah,
right.
How cool is that?
Right?
North Carolina has taken about that
lately.
Massive earthquake rock,
southern Sumatra and Indonesia.
Seven point eight on the Richter scale.
Whoa,
motherfucker.
It's true.
For minutes ago.
This is on these websites.
God Damn,
I love this little latest results thing.
It scrolls down.
It shows you all the shit.
I love that.
Google is the shit.
Okay.
I'm willing to give up some personal
liberty so the google could be running.
Shit.
See what else we've got here,
son.
Um,
these podcast.
Spent a lot of fun and met a lot of
people last week on the road in New York
and in North Carolina.
And thank you all.
Oh very
much for coming out.
And uh,
I'm glad you enjoy the podcast.
We love doing it man.
It's fun as shit.
We a tesla got fucked by Rockefeller.
Yes,
he did.
You know the,
the best version of that story is a
Duncan trussell's drunk history.
I don't have a link to the video,
but I'll put it up before you guys.
I'm going to find the video for you
because it's so cool.
It's funny or die.
Duncan trussell
drunk history.
They get Duncan Super,
super drunk and he asked.
There it is right there.
Job History.
Okay.
I'm going to put this shit on twitter.
Content.
Objective terms.
You going back to that,
your search results.
There was a video in a daily motions
stolen Fox.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Okay.
Don't get in.
Was so wasted it.
They can get on like bottles of Tequila
and shit out.
Absence Block.
Oh yeah.
Absence.
Right,
right.
Have you ever done that shit?
Never did.
The roommate never did enough to have
it.
Like I feel it or anything I don't think
I did a long time ago.
What is is?
Um,
what does Duncan's a Duncan Trussell d
one s or two
to t r U,
s s e l l
I have to keep my mouth props on the
twitter.
It's hilarious.
You gotTa Watch this drunk history
thing.
It's really a pretty spectacular.
But for the people that are tuning into
itunes right now and you ain't,
you get no link.
You motherfuckers,
you don't even know what we're talking
about.
Duncan trussell,
drunk history.
If you google that,
they'll,
they'll be a website up where you can
watch,
you can watch the youtube clip,
you can watch it on funny or die.
You can watch it a couple of different
places.
But it's hilarious.
And Yeah,
a Edison was a con westing house.
There were constant.
Tessa was a genius,
but in their Defense Tesla also fell in
love with a pigeon.
Yeah.
And he had an issue where he destroyed
his sexuality,
like he had some fucking crazy problem
with some actress and he fell in love
with her and you know,
this is all like really vague stuff.
But the,
in his own words,
he destroyed his sexuality and they
don't know if they could cast,
rated themselves.
They don't know what.
It was also a lot of speculation that he
might've been gay or whatever to,
you know,
he was,
he was definitely a loan.
But again,
I think you have to be alone to be like
the fucking greatest genius that the
world has ever known.
I mean that guy was nuts,
man.
That got created all kinds of shit
alternating current and you know,
who you like literally.
I mean you created a way to fucking
broadcast electricity through the air.
You know,
the only problem with it was a,
it would be like free Wifi.
They wouldn't be able to control it.
Like to have it in your house,
you'd just be able to have it.
But I guess now you could have like a
password you've paid for the password.
Well they already do that in some cities
they have city wide Wifi.
Yeah.
It's free.
But I'm not talking about them.
I'm talking about electricity.
Oh,
talking about if they would be able to
do that with electricity,
like and put a password on it.
The way we put a password on Wifi today.
Either way,
Nikolai Tesla is a perfect example of
what we were talking about earlier is a
dude who's just gigantic super fucking
genius.
Like the greatest genius ever end.
Completely Bat Shit Insane.
Just just,
just out of his fucking mind claimed
that all of his information he received
from aliens that he would,
uh,
he would tune into alien signals and
they would tell him I'd do all those
stuff,
you know,
I want,
I always wonder about that man.
I always wonder where the fuck ideas
come from.
You know,
what if ideas are literally like a
living organism.
What if ideas are like,
you know,
when we think about like parasites,
we talked about this before,
like parasites infecting a host,
you know,
and they take over the host body like
that grasshopper that gets infected by
this worm.
The aquatic worms grows inside the
grasshopper to maturity and then when it
gets to maturity,
it convinces the grasshopper that it has
to jump in the water and drown.
So the grasshopper commit suicide so
that this warm can come out of it.
What if like language and ideas
literally are like another sort of
organism and what if like they are
manipulating our consciousness.
You know what if like language and ideas
and all these different things that
people come up with a creativity in
people.
When people are creative about things,
they pull these things down out of the
air.
I mean,
what are you doing?
You freak them out
because I could see it.
I can see today we're going to do this
podcast.
Are you going to play on the fight?
I'm trying to do some tech support here
to see if are you stream shows?
It could be.
We don't need to see it.
We can watch it on here.
I'm not really bothered because you were
not having a conversation.
The conversation,
you're talking about theories and I'm
listening to talk back then,
motherfucker.
I'm not gonna.
Interrupt your theories.
I don't understand why you need to in
there and I've seen this flash of your
fucking line saying that.
I am Brian,
why are you arguing with me?
I am and we're know.
What am I lying.
No,
defending yourself when I'm telling you
it's distracting.
Sorry for listening to you while looking
at trying to do something and doing it
more than it's tech support.
Not at Brian.
Stop arguing with me.
I'm not asking you to do this.
Jesus.
That seems very unnecessary too.
It's not unnecessary.
Brian,
you're distracting me.
You Distract me by Web surfing in front
of me and I'm looking at your screen.
Was I web surfing?
Whatever you're doing,
I'm seeing you fucking flipping through
pages and you're not listening to what
I'm saying.
Okay?
We're not having a conversation.
I.
We weren't having a fight.
You're talking about theory about
something.
I'm listening to thing.
We're doing right here.
This is 724 people
understand.
It's called the podcast show.
You were doing a theory.
I was listening to you watching you flip
through this fucking thing.
You're not listening to me because I'm
trying to do something for the show.
Brian.
Brian,
don't do it.
I told you not to do it earlier
is we're just had a little girl back.
Little hissy fit
the IPADS,
fucking evil ipad.
He's right guys.
Had the IPADS.
Evil.
It's causing you to do that too.
What do you do?
If I wasn't doing that,
I would have been doing the same thing.
We're talking.
I would expect that.
You know when you're talking.
I do the same.
I think we know when people are talking
to each other,
they sit back,
the other person listens to you,
but you're doing a bunch of shit.
I'm just telling you,
man,
I do a bunch of shit while I'm talking.
I know you're not listening to Joe,
Joe,
Joe.
It's not that.
If I were to go off for 15 minutes,
10 minutes at a time,
you would do the exact same thing.
Yes.
You would not what?
We're talking 20 minutes talking about
20 minutes and would you want a podcast?
We're not having this conversation
though.
Brian.
Jesus Christ.
Why are you defending this?
Because your attention.
Really simple.
I'm not attacking.
Yes twice to stop looking at that
fucking thing that it's distracting.
It will look at this thing.
Then it's in front of us doing the same
thing.
No,
it's not because you're not flipping
through things and moving stuff around.
I can tell you not paying attention and
it's distracting me.
Okay.
Sorry.
Damn.
Have I looked into the Illuminati?
What if harp cause the earthquakes.
Shut the fuck up.
Okay.
Whoever you are.
God Damn it with your nonsense.
Go read some David eick books.
Well,
red bands.
The man.
Shut the fuck up.
Jo.
How dare you.
Listen,
we have moved on you fox,
but I have to.
I have to set this board straight.
Well,
we got issues.
Okay.
Let's go to what?
We're going to go to the Rogan board.
Go to my website and find some of the
questions.
People are there to try to change gears
here.
Okay.
Let's get some questions.
Sarah,
can you give us.
Can you talk about being more flexible?
Any books you already recommend on
stretching and flexibility?
Just take yoga.
If you really want to learn how to suck
your own Dick.
That's why you're.
That's why you're asking.
God Damn it.
You said you hung out with Ron Jeremy.
Oh,
he was at the party.
I was at the other day.
Did you guys,
did you hang out with your talk and I
said hi to on that about it.
He used to be able to suck his dick.
That's why I had a bit my act about it,
but he got too fat.
Then the joke was that that's all
overrated.
Sucking your own Dick.
Is
that guy never just sit at home and
watches TV,
does he?
Because that dudes out.
I mean I see that guy at least once a
month.
Yeah,
somewhere he's,
you know,
it's kind of funny.
He's like really into being like a
mainstream or like success,
you know?
He would always tell me about things
that he's done,
like I'm not doing this new movie with
this guy and I'm,
I do a cameo on this TV show,
you know,
and he's like,
I'm trying to make it as a mainstream
actor.
And I'm like,
Dude,
you're fucking Ron Jeremy.
Okay,
and do you understand that you'll like a
hero to ugly fat dudes all across the
world.
You fucked the hottest women on the
planet.
He's fucked all of them.
Every single one of them,
he has a giant Dick and he's fucked all
of them.
Hard slaps them around.
Fuck some doggy style nuts in their
mouth and face.
I mean,
he's a goddamn champion.
He's a champion.
And that was something that you thought
was going to be the thing that you feel
like it can be a champion about.
You know,
like a lot of people are like,
Oh,
you fucking 5,000
hot chicks.
That'd be like,
Oh God,
I feel horrible.
You know
what?
You really think people would think that
that's a bad thing.
Like a regular guy that never gets laid,
that looks like him to a regular guy
that looks like blasting logs look like
that.
That's true.
He looked pretty fonzie back in the day.
Fuzzy.
He was a decent looking guy when he was
younger,
but he was never like a hot stud,
you know?
These girls are tens,
you know what I mean?
And now he's like this gross fat hairy
guy with great chest hairs and he's
still banging them all the new ones.
All the new ones have to to pay homage
to the staff at the thing.
Right.
He's like a superhero for horn.
Yeah.
If you're a dude who looks like him in
Jersey,
you know you're a fucking mailman or
you're,
you know,
you're delivering sausages to the
fucking local supermarket.
Ron.
Jeremy looks like you and he's banging
tens and you can't get laid at all.
You know,
you're lucky if you get some toothless
blowjob from some hunts point hooker
that just makes you check your balls
every five seconds for the next three
days looking for herpes sores.
You know what I mean?
You,
you,
you're lucky if that's,
you know,
that's as good as you can get in and
that's going to cost you a hundred 50
bucks or whatever the fuck it cost Ya,
you know this,
this motherfucker's just bang and you
looks just like you and he's banging
them all.
But hang on,
I can't wait to these chest Harris.
Turn Gray.
Really look sexy.
You everything about shaving that
I hated you.
I fucking hate shaving because what
looks better?
How like being an animal of being a man
or having white little red bumps
everywhere with ingrown hairs and
stubble.
And you look like A.
I just think you're supposed to let it
go.
You're supposed to be a man.
Supposed to be an animal.
Saving your fucking problem,
but she jitsu is if you,
especially with you,
train with the guys grabbed you right
here.
Fuck that.
Grab your,
you know,
your,
your collar and when they grabbed your,
your uh,
your collar that grab fistfuls of chest
hair and it hurts like a motherfucker
might have gay man,
Gay mad key.
You're supposed to have a gay man.
Yeah.
But they grab it through through the
Geek.
I mean that's the.
He gets caught up in the chest hairs
back.
There's a lot of like guard passes where
guys on top of you and he pushes down on
the collar and grabs it and they always
get a fiscal.
People
grab your chest hair,
you get like ringworm staph effects and
there's no reason to be doing Jujitsu.
Definitely hard to justify sometimes.
Think about injuries.
I mean I've gone through since doing
Jujitsu,
I've gone through two knee surgeries,
one meniscus,
one reconstruction.
I've had all sorts of fucking back
problems.
And so why?
Why the.
Why not?
One
of the things like if you had like a
stove that smelled like gas,
you're always burning herself.
There was always flames coming out of
it.
Why would you keep on using that stone?
Why would they keep it
surfing when the crash and get scratched
up?
It's so much fucking fun to keep doing
it.
Jujitsu when you get good at it is
really fun,
Dude.
It's really fun.
You're,
you're,
you're going basically hand to hand
combat and you're doing it with good
friends.
Like these guys that I did you just to,
with,
you know,
you would trust each other with
basically each other's lives,
you know,
when I do get,
gets my back and chokes me and I tapped.
I'm trusting that he's going to let me
go before he fucking kills me because
basically he's got to a point where he's
killing me.
And that's the same thing with you when
you get on top of a dude and you're
finishing off a choke or an arm bar or
something and the guy start tapping.
He's basically trusting that you're not
going to injure him,
you know?
And sometimes people get injured
accidentally,
but the amount of times that I don't get
injured,
it's way more the amount of continent.
Do you know?
I get injured but I've had these
operations and shit over the course of
doing Jujitsu for 14 years.
It's a long ass time,
you know,
and the first year,
so first couple of years I had a knee
issue that I had.
I already had like the knee surgery on
my left knee.
The meniscus,
I have the,
the meniscus problem for years before
that.
So it was a preexisting injury,
so really the only major one that I had
was the knee surgery,
but he's just get it fixed and you
fucking heal up and you've just train
smarter.
Next time you realize,
don't put yourself in bad positions and
don't train with spazzes.
That's another thing.
You've got to make sure you don't train
with anybody that you don't trust.
You know,
it's very important guys.
Uh,
some guys are just a little too nutty.
They,
they fucking spazzed out on you when you
train and you gotta be real careful
those dudes because they want to win so
badly.
The best guys are the guys who were
really good because guys are really
good.
Even though the tap you out,
even though you know they can beat you,
they're going to beat you with technique
and you're much safer.
You literally safer with a guy who can
kick your ass,
who's a black belt than you are with a
guy who's strong,
who's a blue belt because that's strong
blue.
My fucking dive on your foot and break
it.
You know,
he might try to get you into foot locker
and get ahold of it so quick,
trying to tap you out that he hurts you
before you even get a chance to tap.
You know,
it's a,
it's a very tricky thing,
but doing it good is so much fun.
Dude.
It's so much fun.
It's so much fun and it's.
You don't think about anything else.
It really is like a form of meditation.
You know,
when you're in there and you're going at
it and your role in with each other,
you're not thinking about your bills,
you're not thinking about you gotta wash
your car and your laundry.
No.
You're thinking,
I've got to survive here.
I got to get out of the situation.
I got gotta.
You know,
I've got to get into full guard.
I got to pass his guard.
I got him out.
I gotta I gotta finish him.
I got to stop them from finishing me.
That's all you're thinking about is the
moon,
the moment and whenever you're involved
in something like that,
that's that intense.
It's like a form of meditation,
you know,
but don't you think that way about like
art sometimes,
like when you're at your best and your
like with your video editing or whether
you're creating something,
like when you're right in the middle of
it all,
you only thinking about shit but what
you're doing,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's always getting,
getting it done.
It's never like I'm enjoying it.
Oh No,
fuck no.
When I,
when I'm painting a painting,
when I'm editing a video and I'm doing
anything,
it's getting it done.
It's not,
I'm not having,
I'm not having fun while doing it.
They all have spurts of fun while I'm
like going,
oh,
that's a great idea,
but that's not like I'm like bone or
style going,
oh,
I can't wait to finish this.
Really?
Wow.
Yeah,
you don't.
Is that an attitude thing?
Is it I,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean that I,
I guess I consider that you creativity.
I consider I'm trying to get something
out of my brain and do something else as
fast as possible.
While I have the idea in my head,
like I'm trying to take my ideas and
thoughts out of my head and put it in a
form as fast as possible before I lose
the original thought,
right idea.
So it's not like,
oh,
I love this idea.
I can't wait to do it.
Mine is just trying to get what I want.
What I thought of out fast.
I'm making notes with the iphone using
that little uh,
application.
But I don't like that I have to fucking
go in the menu,
find it,
press that,
press record.
I think I'm going to get like a little
tiny voice notes thing and when I have
ideas like that when I'm writing and I
have an idea,
but I'm trying to write it down,
I think I'm just going to press it and
say the idea into it.
So I know for sure that I'm not going to
lose it,
you know?
I mean like,
do you have your iphone night record,
abby?
Just open up program,
hit record.
That's it.
But I want to be able to just one press
and it's recorded.
You know what I mean?
Step two projects for real.
I mean,
it sounds ridiculous,
but it is.
I mean,
it is that.
Yeah,
I mean I have the biggest problem,
like I will have an idea that might be
the coolest thing I've ever thought of
and if I,
uh,
last or wait like five seconds,
10 seconds,
I might accidentally think of something
else.
And that idea has gone down so much and
now I know it's mostly when I was
smoking weed because lately I've been
smoking weed maybe once,
twice a week instead of almost everyday.
And My,
I feel so much sharper.
My memory is so much better.
It's amazing how much better I feel
already and I'm just just from cutting
it.
Well
you also,
you also don't exercise that much
either.
That's a big part about the weed.
You got to blow that out of your system,
you know,
it's not just a.
If you just sit around and just keep
smoking weed everyday,
everyday we'd starts to lose the effect
and then you start to have to get more
weed too to kind of an ad.
You're like,
you're like flooding your system.
You know?
I think that when you smoke weed,
you can you shit,
like if you want to do something
creatively,
you can't smoke too much.
You gotta have one hit,
one hits good.
If you have two or three,
you might lose track of what the fuck
you're talking about.
Sometimes it's fun to have two or three,
but for the most part one it's a little
bit.
I read this or this professor not read
or saw this interview once with this
professor is a um,
uh,
a,
I think he was a physics professor.
Pretty sure when he was talking about
marijuana and he was saying that he
smokes a little bit.
He said that the key is to not overdo
it.
I smoked one hit and I go on walks and I
contemplate my theories,
you know,
and he says that that one hit,
he says it's like a magical push,
like a little boost just helps give
some,
give some,
a little momentum,
little wind in his sails,
you know,
and it starts the ball rolling.
You know,
don't you ever think that like sometimes
you're creating something,
you're trying to do something and you're
not smoking weed and you're like,
God,
so I get anywhere and then you smoke a
little weed and then also Bam,
right?
The main thing I think it is,
it just gives you a different
perspective,
but the same idea that you,
you're,
you're thinking almost like you're
multitasking,
you're thinking one way this way and you
smoke weed and you can think of it a
different way and that's one of the only
ways you could ever do that.
You know,
it's changing your brain.
I mean you probably do it on cough syrup
and think of it a different way,
you know,
but,
but we,
I think is most effective and fastest
and reliable because you're so used to
that
other side.
George Carlin had an interesting take on
writing what he would do,
who is right,
who would write everything first sober,
and then he would smoke a joint and go
over it,
which I think is kind of interesting
because it's kind of like he put up the
skeleton of the house first and then he
starts adding up.
Don't do it the other way around that
because then it always sucks,
you know,
I think if you,
if you die
sometimes you can come up with some
crazy shit and then if you go over it
sober you go,
oh,
this is too ridiculous.
And then you can edit it.
I think the combination of the two is
what's important.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's necessary which
order.
I think.
I think thinking of the idea sober and
then going off on the idea stoned always
helps.
I have better odds that way.
Yeah.
Maybe I think,
uh,
I might want to do that with my writing.
I might want to label it,
you know,
uh,
like s t and s o stoned and sober and
like,
so I'll write s,
t e s o,
so you know,
I did it stone and edited sober or like,
you know,
sos to.
I have some funny stone jokes that I
write and I look at them and they are
fucking crazy.
Let me see if I could pick out one
real quick.
The bit that I do in my act.
That is totally true that I wrote down
something when I was high and then I
went to,
to read it when I was sober and it's
like a unicorn is a donkey from the
future.
I looked at him like,
how could I have ever possibly thought
that that was something that I needed to
write down?
That is for sure a sure.
A sure sign that I got way too fucked
up.
All right.
Here's one of my stone jokes.
Marble,
marble industry has to be hurting right
now.
Remember when you're a kid,
what the fuck does marbles nowadays?
That's actually funny.
That really is funny.
That's awesome.
That's hilarious.
New Comedy tour.
Have to show stoned half silver.
The problem with that is I would have to
like start out sober and then step off
stage,
go outside and get high and that's when
the cops grabbed me because mother
fuckers
twitter,
he laying in.
Wait.
The words on twitter is when you find
out that you're following a fake Lisa
Kudrow,
you feel ashamed and disgusted,
but you're not ashamed that you were
following her to begin with.
I follow everybody.
I can.
I mean there's no one that I follow a
lot of real dummies,
a lot of really dumb celebrities.
It's really annoying an end to
themselves.
I follow people that like give out like
really patronizing advice and like
ridiculous God quotes and just really
dumb shit,
you know,
twit.
Some really dumb shit.
Deepak Chopra is.
Some of this stuff is just like,
why are you fucking talking about Deepak
Chopra?
You don't know who he is.
He's like some really famous authors.
Like a ace has a lot of brilliant shit.
Now I've,
let's do a lot of his interviews.
He says a lot of brilliant shit,
but God damn some of his tweets make me
want to kick him in the Dick.
The balance.
He's missing the balance.
My friends
take a Brownie at the start.
That's not a bad idea,
but the problem with brownies,
brownies and comedy do not mix my
friend.
If I took a Brownie at the start of my
act and our end of the act,
when the Brownie kicked in,
I would be so high.
I would not be able to function.
When I get really high on brownies,
man,
I don't want him to be talking.
I don't want to talk to people.
That stuff's too strong.
I can't trust edibles.
They're like,
it's like doing small amounts of
mushrooms now to me.
Like sometimes I feel like I'm really
tripping and there's.
That's crazy.
That's great.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the eating.
It is spooky man.
And for people that don't know,
it creates something.
When you eat it called 11 hydroxy
metabolite,
that's four times stronger than thc.
So when you eat,
it literally is a totally different drug
than when you smoke it.
That's why people,
when they eat brownies,
they always think they got laced with
something,
you know,
so I can't do that.
So that's the answer to that question.
There's no way I could eat a Brownie,
go onstage than an hour in the brown
kicks in because then I would just want
to lie on my back on stage and start
talking about the universe and you know,
some people might be into it,
but there'd be a lot of people that
would leave and go,
that fucking show sucked.
It was really funny for like an hour and
then he just started talking crazy.
He's lying on his back saying it's
connected to everything and people would
just not,
not enjoy it.
Just take a social dose.
Well,
that's what we're talking about.
We can't figure out what a social dose
is because you don't,
unless you're making the brownies
yourself and then even if you make the
Brahmins yourself,
you could fuck up the first time.
You get it too strong and I don't have
that time to be mastering the right dose
of Brownie.
Smoking is the way to go.
Yeah.
Well,
I loved you in Calgary to jen Ab.
Calgary was the shit that was fun,
man.
That was a good fucking time.
A stone universe tour.
Yeah,
I should do that.
You know,
it would really be cool.
Eventually.
Right now we can't do it,
but eventually when I get to a point
where we can do stone shows,
you know,
like I could do a show like somewhere
like in Amsterdam they have those cafes
where they allow you to smoke weed.
If we had a,
a place like that in America.
Hopefully in November.
Yeah.
Hopefully in November,
but I don't buy it,
man.
I think you don't think that's going to
fucking put the Kibosh on that shit.
The problem with the drug movement is
that making drugs illegal is good for
business and making drugs.
Legal puts a lot of people out of work.
He puts the dea out of work.
It puts private prisons of work.
It puts prison guards out of work.
It puts parole officers and fucking
police officers.
Literally 50 percent of the people that
are in prison are in prison for
nonviolent drug offenses.
How many of those are weed and what
happens when we become illegal?
The,
Oh,
it's a fucking colossal mess.
So what they're doing by keeping it
illegal is really protecting business.
And it sounds crazy.
It sounds like nobody will be doing
that.
There's no way the government staff fuck
up.
No,
it really is.
It's not fucked up.
That literally is what it is.
The reason why it's still illegal is all
because of money.
There's no one dying.
There's no one getting cancer.
There's no one losing their fucking
mind.
There's no yet.
It's still illegal when you can go to
cvs and buy jugs of wine and cheap
liquor and cartons of cigarettes and you
could smoke cigarettes and drink
yourself to death.
Easy,
easy.
You know,
literally you can't die with pot.
I mean you can't.
I mean,
I guess you could do something really
stupid when you're stoned and wind up
killing yourself,
but if you're that dumb,
he probably would've done something
stupid anyway.
You know?
And when they say,
don't dye pot though,
you could totally die if you say start
panicking because your stone and then
your heart had a heart attack.
Die.
I've never heard of that.
Have you?
You would you.
So you don't think that ever happened?
Somebody got sue stone started freaking
out.
Then there are heart fails or something.
I've never heard of it.
Have you heard of it?
Because they can't be saying that.
The weed is like,
let's look,
let's,
let's Google this.
If you're a week ass
bitch,
weak as weak ass.
I'm going to google weekends.
Attack.
Yeah.
Heart attack.
You.
Let's see.
Can Marijuana caused harm tech?
Yahoo answers.
Let's see.
Marijuana said the trigger heart
attacks.
Okay.
This is just wiki answers.
Wiki answers a stupid because people
like answer.
That's how I thought that that whales,
the killer whales used to kill people.
I read this online a couple of different
places to killer whales used to kill
people until World War II and then
people were using the whales as target
practice.
I've read this online and I talked about
on the Adam Carolla show.
And even though I said I don't know if
it's true,
I read it online that after World War
Two,
after the bombers,
killer whales stop killing human beings
and actually started saving,
which would be really fascinating.
Hold on a second.
But it was true.
It was just fucking wicky answers,
man.
Some crazy whaling guy on wiki answers.
And I had to like chase it down on my
website.
Marijuana said the trigger heart
attacks,
Harvard,
five times the amount of having a heart
attack
in the first hour after smoking pot,
a person's risk of heart attack could
rise almost five times.
God Damn.
That's if you're a weak ass bitch
or if you're just one step away from
having a heart attack because they eat a
lot of meat,
you know,
or something like that.
And careful we guess bitches don't want
to write this.
Be careful where you use.
That's why we didn't say that
marijuana's are killed when.
True it didn't.
It didn't.
Employees and anybody,
it didn't,
you know.
But if you have other problems and
he smoked weed or absolutely you can.
Same thing could happen if you lik
shoes.
And you get him out,
there might be something allergic on a
shoe that,
that could trigger off a sinus infection
that will make you die.
I really don't know where you're going
with this.
I have no idea.
Okay.
So I just told her that careful weak ass
bitches,
marijuana can give you a heart attack if
your ticker socks and you can read the
story.
Um,
yeah.
I mean if you really got to get a heart
attack from weed because you're freaking
out.
I definitely think that there's another
problem though.
The real problem is that you're in
terrible shape and you need to take care
of your body.
That's the problem.
It's not pot.
You know,
it's like the way I've always described
pot not being able to help dumb people
is that you can't,
you put jet fuel,
jet fuel and a fucking lawnmower.
It's still a lawnmower.
You know,
you know,
you put jet fuel in a jet and it's
pretty bad ass.
But the bottom line is,
you know,
it's all about what kind of hardware
you're dealing with.
And some people just have wheat brains.
Their brains just suck.
I mean,
have you ever met people and you look in
their eye and you're talking to them and
you're like,
wow,
like there's no hope for this dude.
This dude's just doll.
Like I'm looking in his eyes.
I'm not making any connection.
And just like talking to a dog,
he's like a fucking idiot.
There are people and people don't want
admit this for whatever reason,
because there are people that aren't
dumb.
They're just troubled and their lives
have fallen apart because they,
you know,
they,
they've got all sorts of issues and you
know,
people go,
oh,
that guy's a retard,
but he's not really retired.
You know,
he's kind of smart.
There are people like that that are just
troubled and fucked up and you know,
perhaps they never figured out what it
is in this life that they're good for us
should be doing.
But there's definitely people with cas,
nine volt brains that are just supposed
to be out there digging ditches and to
deny that it's just unscientific.
If you look at the entire fucking
universe,
man,
it's all about things improving and
getting better.
And if you look at human beings,
there's all sorts of things,
there's all sorts of programs and things
set up to make sure that the week can
still survive.
They don't drop off.
And when that happens,
you're going to create a bunch of dumb
people and having those dumb people
around.
Look,
they all fit their purpose.
They're all here for a reason.
But if you're going to have a fucking
Nikolai Tesla,
if you're going to have,
uh,
an Einstein for sure,
you're going to have dick ditch diggers
dudes who are here to ditch Dick's,
Dick's,
you'll have ditches you have.
It's probably,
they'd set the retard are so low in like
the 19 hundreds that they just haven't
raised it yet.
You know,
there should be maybe a test or two that
we have,
we haven't been doing that makes people
that are considered dumb.
They're just retarded.
You know,
like,
you know what I'm talking about?
Like this person is so dumb.
They are retarded.
But you know that their loved one's
passed away for
want to say that because we want to say,
Oh,
you know,
you give people a chance and you know,
everyone's got a chance.
I think there are.
There are certain people where it's very
much cultural.
It's very much they're,
they're,
they're just,
they're raised in an environment where
no one's questioning anything there.
Their role models are all dunces that
grew up in a family of people who scream
and yell at each other for no reason.
And they just,
they live in this stupid world.
And so they,
they imitate their and they become
stupid themselves.
There's,
there's people like that.
So it's,
it's not an exact science,
but the problem is there's a lot of
really fucking dumb people,
man.
When you see those videos of those
people that go to those Sarah Pailin,
book signings,
those teabag or people and they're all
up in arms against the government.
There are some wooden minds and there
just some doll motherfuckers,
you know,
that's,
that's really a problem that everybody
has to have a say.
Like,
how do you fix that?
How do you fix what we got going on as
far as like the idea of a democracy,
the idea of,
you know,
half the people you know or more have to
agree or have to have to.
I mean the idea of a real democracy.
If,
if more than 50 percent of people
retarded,
which I think they are,
I would say more than 50,
more than 50 percent.
How the fuck do you move forward?
How the fuck do you.
The only way to do it is to make those
people smarter,
is to figure out a way to educate those
people to,
to raise the number of dom raised the
number of uninterested,
uninvolved or 50 percent or retarded.
Like,
like they have bad brains or just
education environment.
Well,
you know,
I have,
I know people that are great people,
but for whatever reason they just don't
think the same way that other people,
my other friends do,
you know,
like they don't,
they're not thinking about like,
uh,
putting your seatbelt on because they
don't want to get in a car accident.
Just get in the car and just drive.
You know.
Right,
like there's,
they just don't have as like a part of
their brain is not working.
Like,
like,
uh,
the deep,
like just thinking outside the box
thing,
if you think that's how they were
raised,
is it nature or nurture?
I think it's,
I think it's just,
they're not using the same parts of
brains,
their brain,
you know,
it's almost like,
I just don't think that they have that
in him,
you know?
I don't know.
I,
I really,
I wonder how much of that is due to a
environment,
like how much of it is due to pollution,
you know,
how much of it is due to what your
mother was eating and doing while she
was watching is probably totally that.
Totally.
That,
that has to have a big effect.
You know?
I mean if you go on Youtube and search
me smoking cigarettes,
you'll see some just guy in West
Virginia just sit near smoking a
cigarette and you can tell just by
looking at him,
he's retarded,
but yeah,
he is probably not considered retarded.
No.
Any can vote.
Yeah.
Anticonvulsant.
Like I had a conversation.
I've been having all these conversations
about religion on the Robin Board lately
because all this Catholic scandal that's
going on,
and I don't know if you know the latest,
but they've proven that the pope knew
about pedophiles and hid the cases that
went before he was the pope,
that he knew about these pedophile cases
and he did everything that he could to
shield the information and protect the.
The priests.
That's like,
man,
how could you not think that the
Catholic religion as a cult at that
point,
at that point,
it's a cult,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it's a cold period definition
wise,
but at that point in time you're like,
how could this possibly be good?
You know,
if at the very top this kind of shit is
going on,
how do people get tricked into that?
How,
how was that possible?
You know,
how,
how are people so silly
that in 2010 this is still considered a
possibility?
Like maybe they're right,
maybe these kid fuckers are on the ball.
Maybe they're the ones that we need to
follow.
You know,
maybe this crazy organization in Italy,
maybe they're the masters of all the
knowledge like that's,
that's.
Is that nature,
is that nurture?
What does that.
It's both.
I don't know.
No,
I think it's.
I think it's the same thing that when
you talk to certain people they don't
get technology like they,
they,
they're not informed as much as other
people.
Is that nature is that nurture?
I mean how could people see to me and to
you when we look at gadgets and new
things like you know what both,
like Brian,
we'll find some new thing online,
like Holy Shit,
look at this and they'll send it to me
or I'll send something to him,
you know,
and you look at it,
you're like,
oh,
what are they doing?
Look what they're doing with that.
This multitouch fucking interface.
Like a minority report type shit or
anything,
anything new thing.
That stuff becomes fascinating man.
I think though the
later,
the more we kind of kill off a certain
age group of people that didn't grow.
I think the more people are going to
research for themselves,
religion and stuff like that.
I think religion is probably their
future and the religion is probably
going to be a lot different in say the
next hundred years.
Yeah,
ever been ever.
I think it's probably more people have
realized how ridiculous it is now than
ever before.
You know,
I don't think there's ever been more
questioners and there's probably never
been more options either.
You know,
with scientology and the moonies and
anything else and new ones that are
popping up left and right.
There's all these new ideologies that
are,
that are popping up left and right.
People are offering like new
alternatives,
you know,
and it can't last.
It's just,
it's going to be too much.
There's gonna come a point in time where
we know the truth.
We know it's not going to be something
that we have to like wonder and make a
judgment call on.
It's going to be like,
oh,
I know you're full of shit.
Oh,
I know you're lying.
I know.
The information you're giving me is not
truthful.
I can read this and I can understand
this.
We have an intuitive sense of what's
wrong and what's right.
We also have an intuitive sense of when
people are lying,
you know,
when someone is not being honest with
you or,
or when you ever been talking to someone
that you know,
that they're secretly hoping that
something goes wrong with you.
Like there's some secret hate,
you know,
you ever been talking to someone
well on the Internet everyday.
Yeah.
But you know,
you know that feeling where somebody
really is like,
they're being douchey to you.
Like there's something there and it's,
you can't describe it,
but you get a feeling from them.
You know,
there's instinctual feelings that we
have and deception is a big one.
Man.
That's a big one.
When someone's being deceptive and
someone's lying to you or does that not
drive you fucking bananas?
Doesn't that drive you crazy?
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
but you have to also think that the
person,
the reason why this person's acting like
this or something like that,
it's because it's something that they
don't like that you've done to them.
Or is that something that you do or you
know,
so then you have to eight.
But that's not always the case.
Sometimes throwing shortcomings,
it's causing them to be a cure.
I mean,
you know,
I mean we're talking about earlier this
girl that's upset of this other girl,
you know,
I mean think about that.
I mean,
what does that,
where is that coming from?
That's not.
And no one did anything wrong there.
You know,
it's like sometimes it's their own
shortcomings is people choosing you over
another person,
someone seeing something that someone
else has and saying,
well that should be me.
How can this guy successful?
How come this girl is so happy and I'm
not.
They get angry.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of shit to human beings
that's not logical,
you know,
and,
but we can feel that when you're talking
to someone and you.
I mean,
how many times you talked to a dude,
I've,
I've talked to a bunch of dudes where I
know there's some,
some weird jealousy hate thing when I'm
talking to them and I tried to be as
nice as friendly as possible and like,
listen man,
we're just meeting for the first time,
but I don't really know.
Okay.
You don't,
don't make this a personal issue,
you know,
you think you have this,
this,
this rivalry with me because you know,
you see me on television and you don't
like the fact that I'm doing something
that you want to do,
but I'm just a dude.
You know,
you're a dude.
I'm a dude.
And the reality is I'm not taking your
job.
Okay?
The reality is I got this job and the
other reality is you can get something
like it.
Do,
you know,
you can become exactly like me except
your own version of it.
You know,
you can.
Anybody can do it.
Anybody can be successful in any,
any area that they pursue.
You just have to figure out your way
through the fucking path.
It is possible,
you know,
I mean,
look,
muggsy bogues was a fucking basketball
player who is five foot six,
you know,
I mean,
anything's possible.
You know,
there's,
there's just has to be your own path.
You know,
and I think human beings especially have
a real problem being jealous of other
people and being upset at other people.
But you can what?
One of my point is that you could feel
that when someone does that to you and
we're going to be able to tell when
people are lying,
we're going to eventually going to be
able to tell.
That's for sure.
More like something that we're evolving
in us with language and with
consciousness.
We're figuring out deceptive behavior.
We're figuring it out because we
understand that we recognize it in
yourself and the more truthful you are,
the more easy it is to pick out laws and
other people.
Yeah,
and just so much information to.
They were just like twitter alone is
probably killed a million relationships
and a million rumors too and then I
can't do anything nowadays.
Like imagine being married and imagine
going to a bar and then you'd meet as
girl and you start talking to her and
somebody goes,
Oh hey,
there's that person takes a photo of you
puts it on their twitter.
Now you are just being caught in front
of 5 million people.
You know,
you can't.
You pretty much have.
We going to have to all have to start
wearing disguises like fake mustaches
and stuff.
And I know it's going to be,
it's going to be like that
fucking movie with Tom Cruise.
What was that?
Crazy.
But we want to.
Stanley Kubrick's last movies wore masks
on.
They.
They Bang each other.
Oh yeah.
With a.
What the
fuck was that with Nicole Kidman?
Nicole kid.
What the hell was that moving?
Somebody knows Stanley Kubrick.
Was that shit?
Some fucking come up with it.
I'm just going to sit here until
somebody comes up with this chick says,
don't cheat.
Then.
How hilarious are you Jenna?
BBB?
No.
Nobody knows the answer.
This fucking movie.
What is this God damned movie?
Eyes Wide Shut.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course you shouldn't cheat.
But the problem is dudes want to.
And we're programming
what does not even cheating.
Like you could have just met this person
at a bar set high and just started
talking.
But you know,
Mr.
camera phone behind you took a picture
of you and now you're fucking,
you know,
it doesn't like shit's all crazy.
You can't do any short.
But.
But the reality is,
the reason why it's an issue at all is
that human beings,
especially men,
are wired to try to populate an entire
village because that's how the best
sperm survives.
And you know,
that's why all these crazy conquer
motherfuckers like tiger woods,
you know,
these guys that are so uber competitive.
That's why I had so many checks,
you know,
it was like guys just doing nature.
He spread his seed.
If this was 2000 years ago,
that would be totally normal.
But it's like an offshoot,
you know,
it's an offshoot of a,
a fucking warrior instincts,
you know,
he's out there conquering and then he's
conquering.
No,
he's doing what he's supposed to do.
He's like driving forward.
Women are wired to grab a man and keep
him for protection.
Yeah,
that's true too.
That's definitely true.
Sex addiction is total bullshit.
Is it you sex addicted
mother would have to disagree because I
know some people that are totally
addicted to sex and a different level
than I am.
You don't know.
You never met some friends of mine.
Do you ever talk about the Saran wrap or
the
lotion?
No,
you said talking about front who uh,
you should do a thing called shooting
and what he would do is he would get
these running pants,
like those on those really thin,
sort of like,
it's almost like a nylon nylon,
really silky running pants.
And he would literally rub the crotch
with a fine grit sandpaper and,
and then he would a baby oil,
his balls and his shit is junk and baby
oil,
everything.
So it's all nice and slippery.
So he takes this super thin running
pants and he puts them on over his baby
oiled shit.
And then would go get lap dances and
they were just shooting this past
[inaudible] girl would be hot and she'd
be riding on.
It's difficult hard.
It was literally like sex,
like a.
and he had,
he was like obsessed with his work.
He has his own company and so he would
work like these long hours and you know,
and you know,
he was really successful.
Millionaire had the whole thing.
No big fucking house in the hills.
They,
he had the whole package and he worked
all day.
He was so he had no time for
relationships and he like had some bad
experiences with women so he thought
women were just trying to rip him off
and this chip that he was dating,
she,
she wound up cheating on him and he
like,
he got his heart crush so he just
decided to just go shooting and this
would be his day.
He would,
uh,
go to work,
work day.
Then he would get something to eat and
then he would go shooting or he would go
shooting on the way home and then he
would get something to eat and then go
to bed,
do it all over again.
And that was his.
All of his relationships were lap
dances.
He would just go,
we got caught eventually.
Did any or he fucked up once and he went
and he put too much baby oil or I think
he used lube and literally his pants
were soaked.
And so the girl,
the girl sat,
I'm sure like,
what the fuck would she like?
She's like,
pissed himself,
just like,
what are you doing?
What's wrong with you?
It's like,
I'm sorry,
he said I was so embarrassed and he left
and he leaves with this puddle and his
pants of baby oil and move and it's like
dripping into his socks and shit.
That's a Dixon Dixon mean.
I think it's kind of like,
because he's into massages.
He was into like big rewarded for his
hard work.
He was into like fine food and massages
and if prostitution was legal he would
just hire a hooker.
So like if there's like a,
if it was like an acceptable normal
thing to do,
like you've lived in some foreign
country,
you know,
they were,
they allow prostitution.
He would just go to the prostitutes and
get serviced and then go home.
You know there's a fucking,
you know,
I don't,
I don't understand how people have
allowed that to be illegal.
How do you stop that?
Why do you stop that?
Stop people.
Health reasons I think you don't want
fucking aids going ramp.
It hurt everyone.
Having herpes really though is that
either.
But if you go to brothels,
they have to check those girls.
They test those girls.
If you go to a brothel in a country
that's respectable,
supposedly they're testing those girls
just like they test porn stars,
you know,
I don't think it's a good argument
because I think that if you're paying
attention more,
it's a lot safer than if,
you know,
if it's some fucking underground thing
where these,
you know,
it's probably a lot of violence that
comes with it too though,
you know,
people going a little bit too far and
raping the person falling.
But if wouldn't it be safer if they did
it in a brothel where their security and
when people get screened and they know
someone's not crazy,
purity,
they're everywhere.
I mean,
that makes much more sense to me than
some poor girl has to put a fucking add
in some magazine and then show up.
Normally that girl that came to the
comedy store,
one night,
we'll talk to her,
she said she was a hooker and she would
respond to ads and she would,
uh,
she would only go to them,
right?
She wouldn't let them come to her as I
would have worked.
She would go to them so that she had an
address,
you know,
and she would tell her friend,
hey,
this is where I went,
so if anything happens to me,
I don't come back,
you know,
somebody killed me,
and she would,
you know,
she would go to these places,
peoples places and she would fuck it was
like,
it was crazy.
She like super awesome about it.
You remember that Shit.
What was it?
She was meth.
She was a method,
wasn't that,
but she told us,
told us what you did.
Yeah,
I think she said she did the mess,
you know,
and then you could,
if you had like a real brothel,
I think there'll be a lot less crime.
There will be certainly way less rapes
if you just get laid,
you know,
and people would settle down and you
know,
it's like the,
this when you really did fall in love
and you're really with a woman,
like there wouldn't be this,
like this overwhelming desire to be with
someone just to have sex because you
could always have sex so you could just
pay for it if you want to.
But you know,
being in a relationship would,
a relationship where you really enjoyed
being with that person,
you know,
they wouldn't like,
especially if you live in a place where
it's hard to get laid,
I'll give you live in Boston or
something like that.
It's hard to get laid in.
Boston is.
It's not easy,
man.
Those gusts.
What do you want to use?
Me?
You just don't want to use me to get the
car.
You drive home.
Oh,
I didn't even know women were the nights
until I moved to California.
Man,
I had no idea.
No,
that's funny.
It's true.
Totally true.
That's angry people.
So God damn cold.
It's cold.
It's just a God damn disaster.
You know?
There's a lot of,
a lot of tension,
you know,
and a lot of people,
they're all go get them to,
you know,
they moved their,
they're immigrants.
You know,
the grandparents were immigrants and
they moved there from another country
that's not some serious.
Go get them shit.
Take all your stuff,
pack it,
get in a boat,
sail across the fucking world,
and starting some new place and learn
the language and learn how to it.
That's how go get these people were.
So the people that initially came to
this country on the east coast,
those are all savages.
And the people that went west or all the
people that want to get away from
establishes all the people were like,
these fucking people are crazy.
Get Me Outta here.
And they all took off and the furthest
they could get was here.
That's why people in California are like
the most laid back in the most
progressive.
I mean,
it literally is because they're the ones
that are the ancestors of the ones that
wanted to get the fuck away from where
they were,
you know.
So let's go try the thin running pants
next time you're in Houston.
Um,
I don't think so,
man.
I think you'd probably still get
diseases within running pants,
but a listen,
it's a fucking,
it's an excellent possibility.
I should add that whole story to my
house.
Vegas routine.
It's totally true.
Joe Always talks about 2012 new topic.
Who the fuck are you talking about?
Dummy?
I'll keep answering this chick's tweets.
When did we talk about 2012.
We didn't bring that up.
I have no idea.
Poker shut your mouth shut.
You're dirty.
Dirty mouth.
This guy says I use naturally speaking.
Nine point five on the PC.
It's pretty good.
I have a little bit of speech impediment
due to my cerebral palsy.
You speak much clearer than I do,
so you should have no problem.
I believe there's a new version.
Huh?
I wonder though,
if that's the pc one is better.
Does anybody know if the better pc,
the pc one rather is better than the Mac
one or is it the exact same sense if,
if the PC ones better used to be that
way?
It used to be the,
the uh,
that the pc one was better.
It definitely used to be.
But uh,
I don't know.
Now the Mac users,
like eight percent.
Ten percent of the population or
something.
What is it now?
Eight?
Yeah.
What percentage is it?
Man?
I have no idea.
There is a mental game,
one can play called channel the alien
when one
can find the answers to complex
questions simply by visualizing an
ancient alien from beyond pretending to
channel the answers.
Try it sometime.
You'll be surprised.
Okay,
so would this guy is saying this holy
chaos.
Twenty three is that you can find the
wise answers to things by pretending to
channel an alien who has the wise
answers.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Why don't even think about that.
Are you getting.
We'd Bitch.
Okay.
Because that shit is strong.
It's a little too strong for you.
You're,
you're off the track and into the woods.
Okay.
You're fucking train is knocking over
trees right now.
That doesn't make any sense.
I,
I guess I kind of see what you're
saying.
You know,
and I sort of do that sometimes where I
say to myself,
okay,
if I wasn't me,
how would I advise myself?
And I pretend that I'm talking to a,
a much more intelligent version of me
guiding my life.
I do do that,
but I don't pretend it's God damn alien.
You know?
I just try to think of what is
objectively separate myself from my life
and what's the best advice I could give
myself if I was smarter than I am.
I started about it again and mad at
myself.
Yes.
That's funny.
Tell me Shit ever.
I think.
I think you're silly fellow.
Channel the alien.
Okay.
Louis Guy.
Puny human.
The reason red band isn't paying
attention,
it's because you talk about the same
shit every show.
Then don't tune in faggot.
You don't have to like it.
It's all free.
Bitch Ron.
Jeremy fucked your roommate.
Whoa.
Somebody's roommate.
Got Fuck by Ron.
Jeremy.
Uh,
I'm glad you like them,
dude.
All right.
Let's go to page one.
She questions we've got here.
How do you think the world would turn
out if it were to be divided by
believers and nonbelievers?
Would the believers eventually end up
just raping and murdering the
nonbelievers into their cult?
I hate these questions.
You know the,
the real problem with believers and
nonbelievers is nobody fucking knows you
don't know,
and nobody knows.
You shouldn't be a goddamn believer.
We should it be a questionnaire which
try to figure things out,
but what I need,
whenever anybody tells you they got the
answers,
that person's either full of shit or
they want your money,
period.
No one has the answers.
You don't know.
It's impossible.
There's no way.
Have I listened to any Daniel Dennett
lectures?
No.
I don't know who Daniel Dennett is.
Do you know dental than it is now?
I will never find information.
Some more information.
See,
that didn't go off on me about the last
APP.
Podcast.
How about politics?
Yeah.
Emailed me.
He made a threat about it.
He fucking tried to contact me on some.
I am.
It's an interesting topic.
No,
because I go back and forth on it and I
agree with you to a certain extent.
It really is silly.
I'm to do.
You can waste so much of your energy
thinking about politics,
but then you know,
the argument is we're supposed to be
governing ourselves,
governing ourselves in this country and
that you get the option to vote and you
know,
you get the right to express your
opinion.
You can actually change the world.
But I don't know if you can,
you know,
I'm not completely convinced at this
point with the amount of money that
they're able to contribute to campaign
funds that giant corporations are able
to,
they're,
they're literally shaping the way people
see things,
they're putting ads and,
and,
and manipulating people's thoughts and
getting people to believe things that
aren't necessarily true.
Also,
they can push a certain agenda so that
somebody can make money.
I mean,
the situation is totally corrupt.
so much money is involved in politics
now and so much money is involved in,
you know,
in running the world and you know,
just look at what Obama's done with
this,
all this fucking bailouts and this.
When you look at this whole healthcare
system thing,
someone has to be making money.
There's no way they'd be putting this
much effort into this whole healthcare
thing if it was just about,
you know,
keeping people healthy and making sure
that people have medical coverage.
It's not there,
they're just there,
there's money involved in it.
It's corruption,
it's gonna get crazy and it's a goddamn
money grabbed just like the bailout is.
And it's all very,
very boring to me.
And the real thing about it is it does
get boring.
It's a real thing about it is you can
never have all the information.
It's impossible.
It's a trap.
I care about the things I want to care
about,
about the government.
Meaning if they decided to make a bill
about banning the internet or that
night,
cats are going to be illegal.
They don't care about that part.
That's not part of it.
But I'm not going to sit there and try
to figure out everything from a to z
about our government and freak out about
it because you know what I.
I'm freaking out about my mail being
delivered today.
You know,
I'm thinking,
how am I going?
Shit.
If I did that,
I'll just be an angry person.
It would argue shit.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
I see you
point.
But people could also argue that that's
apathy.
People could say that that's what's
wrong with this country is that people
don't care.
But I say that until someone
acknowledges the fact that this system
is broken,
we need a radical overhaul of the
system.
A complete restructuring of the way we
do business in this country.
It's called moving to Canada.
It's not even moving to Canada because
they're corrupt too.
There's a big fucking.
Yeah,
there's
a big scandal.
The Minister of Finance,
I believe it was involved in a big
scandal in Canada.
People are corrupt.
It's human beings.
People are less corrupt in places where
people are less ambitious like Canada,
where people are more laid back and
friendlier,
you know,
and that's one of the things that's cool
about Canada.
People are just like,
they're less crazy up there.
They're a little cooler,
a little calmer,
you know,
I think that I think,
you could waste your whole life trying
to understand the system and be a part
of it and argue and go to court and it
will become your everything.
And it's a system that we're born into.
We're born into this system that we did
not choose.
We have no control of and it's so
comprehensive
and so fucking intertwined that just to
study a single branch of it would take
up all of your time if you just wanted
to understand the stock market.
That shit would take up every fucking
hour of every day of your life.
Just trying to figure out how all that
shit worked and even then look at that
fucking guy that,
that,
that Bernie made off.
Motherfucker.
That guy was ripping off people who
understood the business.
That kind of ripped off everybody.
He ripped off millionaires and shit.
He ripped off fucking Steven Spielberg,
you know,
he ripped off all these like really big
name people.
So that means nobody knows how it works.
Nobody understands that thing.
Could you imagine if your whole life is
dedicated to studying the stock market?
You're supposed expert people ask you
for advice.
Anyone you got fucked.
You could say God damn con game.
Nobody understands it.
Fuck politics.
It's not politics.
We're talking about now we're talking
about the whole system.
We're talking about money,
we're talking about everything and we're
talking about this attitude of fuck
politics,
just like what,
what can be done?
That's the big question.
What,
what can be done to make the world
better?
If you had any say in,
you know,
trying to figure out what direction we
could go to make everything easier for
everybody.
What would you do?
Have everything be a lot.
Make a lot more sense.
Because right now everything from the
schools taxing.
Do you know everything about the
government makes no sense to the average
person,
but if they can have like a website,
you have to go to everyday and go,
okay guys,
today's topic of the day.
Do you think that slavery's legal?
Yes.
No.
And then have the whole country vote
right there.
Make it super planned out and easy and
make it something like that.
Because right now no one gives a fuck
what's going on on,
you know,
you started talking about it
occasion and money and stuff like that.
Then you get into really complex
subjects.
It's not that simple as like having
people vote because then he runs the
same issue,
like people just put out propaganda,
Oh,
if slavery is not legal,
that means the Iraqis will attack us and
they'll rape your baby and next thing
you know slavery's legal again.
Yeah,
I know,
but it shouldn't be.
It should be a vote though system
because right now it's like no one gives
them online.
Like if there's a vote online,
whether or not you should be killed
tonight.
Right now,
if people watch this podcast,
maybe 60 percent of the people would
want you to.
Obviously that's how crazy they are.
I know that.
That's true.
It is like allow penciled out of the way
all this shit's all broken anyway.
You can't fix it.
No matter what.
Me read bad things about fucking any of
it doesn't matter.
It's going to happen the way it's going
to happen.
Just called yourself by your Internet
name.
I know.
That's what that.
From that,
from that thread,
everyone's.
Everybody was calling me and I get third
person cares about a red band.
You know what?
Raymond was designed for?
Mac,
computers and cats and you know I agree
completely because who the fuck cares?
I can't change anything and even if I
could one person,
I don't want to devote my life to see if
I could or not,
I don't give a fuck about that.
It's like baseball and it
was a real problem is it does take away
from everything that you enjoy and
people say,
well,
you have to fight for your rights really
to you just have your rights.
That's the real God damn problem.
The real problem is that I have to think
about this fucked up system.
Not all that.
It's so broken.
You have to keep an eye on it 24 hours a
day because people are just stealing and
getting us into wars and making terrible
decisions and they'll blame it on all
these troubles that are happening in
other countries.
But when you start fucking reading into
it and you find out the shit that we do
that causes all these troubles,
you know,
God damn.
No wonder why everybody fucking hates
us.
We got our dirty little fingers in
everything,
so it's like,
it's not me.
It's not me that has my dirty little
fingers in Afghanistan and Iraq and you
know,
and fucking all sorts of shit that goes
on in third world countries and it's not
you either.
You should be able to fucking pursue
what you want to do and the idea that
you have to go over there and kill some
people to do that.
It's just damn.
In 2010,
we pretend like you go to Australia.
Like when we went to Australia recently,
dude,
people in Australia are so fucking cool.
They're so fun to be around such a
friendly culture.
What if we decided to go to war with
Australia?
I'm not.
Would that be all a sudden we're
supposed to be tricked into believing
that we have a problem with this
continent that we'd never been probably
happened in our lifetime.
If it didn't.
I mean it's because we're going to war
together as a group against some other
motherfuckers.
I mean,
that's really the only reason why we're
not.
Because we've decided to band up and go
jack these fools and take their shit,
but it's,
it's,
it's amazing that you know,
our system.
There's no other system though,
I mean when you get 300 million people
in place,
what the fuck?
There's no other model of how to run a
300 million person empire and to do it
correctly where people think it's fair
because people are just.
It's part of life is an intelligence
test and part of the intelligence test
is how susceptible are you to
manipulation.
You know what I mean?
Literally it's like a game.
It's like there's people like these
evangelists that you see,
you know,
at 3:00
in the morning that are fucking talking
a certain cadence and especially that
black guy with a hot dog rolls in the
back of his neck.
You know,
that guy I'm talking about that
motherfucker is always,
you know,
spouting out some Bible Shit,
but he's doing it so charismatic and
he's sweating like a pig and everybody
in the audience is going bananas and
it's an intelligence test.
Intelligence test is,
do you believe this guy is so confident
and speaking so clearly?
Do you believe what he's saying?
Because if you do,
you're a dumb ass.
You know,
he's just tricking you by being so
confident in what he's saying.
And that's what it really is.
It's like this whole,
this whole world is like a gigantic
intelligence tests and even at the
highest level people are failing left
and right.
If you start getting into these,
the,
you know,
the Republicans want to control the
house and like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like,
look what you're talking about.
You're talking about nonsense.
If everybody just stepped back and said
this is all nonsense,
this whole thing sucks.
Stop.
We're not going to fucking keep going
with windows 95.
Shut the fuck up.
Okay.
Windows 95 sucks.
We need some new shit.
Okay.
Do you have empty?
Do you have windows?
2,000,
whereas Vista,
whereas windows seven,
you motherfuckers.
Where's MCA?
Wes knows me.
Those dark dark time in American
history.
You know,
we need a better operating system.
And the problem is we don't,
we just keep patching up the same stupid
fucking system we've always had.
So what do you do?
Do you just sit back?
No,
you don't move because you moved.
They're going to be under control of
some other mothers.
I look at it,
it's like if you have a neighbor's dog
that's barking,
you know,
you can either sit there and deal with
it for as long,
but once it gets too bad you have to do
something about it.
And so that's how I feel about it.
If I still wake up and everything's
fine,
nothing's really affecting me on an
everyday basis,
enough to care about it,
then I'll be fine.
But if something crazy happens,
like they decided to do something that's
going to affect me,
then I'll just be like,
you know what?
Fuck you.
I'll move on because I don't give a
fuck.
Like I'm not like United States or for,
for the rest of my life.
I don't care.
You know,
like I'm sure
move a bunch of times,
move around a bunch of times in this
country you realize the United States
doesn't have one mentality and then when
you move or when you travel to other
places,
you're like,
God,
I could live here,
can easily live with.
It's a huge planner.
Dude.
England is pretty dope.
I like living in the weather kind of
socks or rains a lot,
but to the people you fun.
I enjoy it there.
I love doing shows in England.
England is fucking fun.
You know you could live in England,
you can live in Australia,
you'd have,
you would have no problem in Sydney.
Do it.
You'd have to wear sunscreen.
That's it.
They get no ozone.
Layer it up there to.
Everybody gets jacked.
There's skin cancer,
less ramp.
They have these big ads on billboards
about skin.
Cancer is everywhere.
It's a real problem.
But do the people are friendly though.
The weather's beautiful.
You know the fucking,
the coastlines.
Gorgeous.
It has no problem there.
No.
The idea that this one fucking place,
you know the from one ocean to another
ocean that's like so 5,000
years ago,
you know,
that we're fighting for our land like
Jesus Christ,
especially in America,
to think that where they just,
when we're,
you're a citizen in America,
you are just like riding in the balls of
the Dick.
That's fucking the world.
You're just a part of this gigantic
machine.
It's just bone in the world.
You know,
two planes come over here and smash into
buildings and we lose our marbles and we
wind up killing a million civilians in
Iraq and justifying it that we're
keeping ourselves safe over here.
It's fucking nuts,
man.
What's the answer?
God dammit.
Internet people.
What's the answer?
Twitter people.
There's No God damn answer.
There is no god Damn fucking answer.
It doesn't exist.
You lose your marbles.
You can't buy new ones because they
don't make them anymore.
Yeah.
The marble industries.
We're at A.
we're at a businessman.
Yeah.
Pretty soon.
I think it's almost going to be like how
the Internet,
uh,
kind of like in the old days I wasn't
talking to people from England every day
in Australia and that kind of broke that
wall.
I think in the future there's not gonna
be like,
well,
it's religion kind of fizzes out fizzles
out a little bit more.
I think even just countries are going to
fizzle out more because we're probably
going to be just teleport into Japan
every day.
You know,
like,
Hey,
every go to Japan,
I'll be
right back to me.
Definitely dissolved.
And the only thing that keeps us in this
one,
this one idea is travel,
another difficult to get in planes.
Then when you land,
you have to be screened for what's the
next plan plan.
Plan.
It's probably going to be sending our
brainwaves to another body in Japan that
we have like a backup body and if we get
to a position or we talked about before,
like we talked about,
like twitter and facebook and this
connectivity that people share right
now,
it's like we're connected so much more
now than we've ever been before.
If we really do get to a place where no
secrets will exist,
where everyone will know everything,
you'd be able to read each other's mind
will be able to access each other's
information.
Maybe that's the only way we'll ever
really have like a real government will
really realized that we really can't
bullshit things that we used to have to
come clean about.
The fact that we live in a dictatorship
that's dressed up as a democracy where
these gigantic corporations are making
millions of dollars because we just have
to just,
just accept the fact that we're under
their rule the same way they accepted
the fact when they lived,
you know,
in England they were under the rule of
the king and you know,
and all these different countries that
are controlled by,
you know,
by monarchs,
they have to accept that it's clean and
then they know what the fuck it is.
Like in Thailand there's a Goddamn Qing
period.
That's what it is.
There's a king and you got to deal with
that shit.
You can't talk shit about them and maybe
it's either that or we realize we can't
do that anymore.
We realized we can't live like this
anymore.
Maybe that's the only thing that's gonna
save us.
Maybe this technology,
you know,
maybe it'll get the people who are
actually running things to realize how
ridiculous it is when everybody knows
they're bullshit.
I don't know man.
It's a fucking.
It's a tricky situation.
You know,
student,
we are completely headed towards an age
for lies and deception will fade away.
Yet we will never understand all of
everything.
I think that's what we were just talking
about.
So that's contradictory.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
But we're just talking about what's,
what's here right now and you know what,
what may or may not be possible in the
future.
I mean,
the idea that we're gonna get to an age
where everything is connected.
That really is speculation,
man.
I mean,
we don't really know if we're ever going
to get that far.
We don't know if we're going to get hit
by a gigantic meter or fucking polarized
caps or shift or when you look at the
history of the earth,
who the fuck knows what the hell's going
to happen to us?
You know,
there's always some new shit going down.
No,
you know what the nuttiest thing about,
about like I was watching these solar
system documentaries today,
the nuttiest thing is how many different
planets had been hit by planets.
You know,
like they were.
There was a thing on uranus about how
they recognize those rings around your
anus and they believed it was some sort
of a collision and they were talking
about moons colliding.
Then eventually your ransom Williams
there,
they're real close to each other.
Eventually in a slam I knew each other
like,
damn.
Imagine if we realize that earth was
getting hit by a planet.
It was like 100 years away if we saw
planners.
Yeah,
I mean how long would it take for a
planet to hit us?
I mean like I think they were saying
that your readiness is a year,
like a year and your readiness is like
hundreds of years.
I think it was 160.
I don't remember what it was.
It was a bunch of years.
They're there.
Their winter alone was like 60 plus
years.
I think that's what they're saying.
How,
how many,
you know,
that's a long ass time.
How many years would be able to
recognize like if a plant was headed our
way,
like if there was an inter inter solar
system,
intruder a got like a plant that's in
another,
the solar system.
It's coming,
it would be faster.
It just seems like it would just happen
faster for some reason,
even though it probably isn't,
but why would it seemed like that if it
takes a year for the earth to go around
the sun,
right?
Doesn't.
That was not what the whole deal.
I mean it's like it's,
I guess spins like asteroids.
It goes around the sun and heat
year.
Right?
That's pretty God damn close and it
takes us a year to go around.
If some shit was coming in from another
planet,
it wouldn't come that fast.
What it.
Unless we're moving towards it as it's
moving towards us.
Who the fuck knows?
The point is that's happened that
literally has happened to Earth.
There used to be earth one which was
just a different planet and then it got
hit by a planet and that created the
moon fucking nuts,
man.
We that,
that would end all the bullshit.
All the tiger woods,
all the Jesse James,
all the fucking healthcare and tea
baggers and you know,
rush limbaugh and Glenn back,
all that Shit would just stop.
If we saw a giant planet in this guy
that got a little bigger every day,
whole Lee fuck,
could you imagine
it?
Probably be pretty cool if it wasn't
going to hit in your lifetime.
Now it probably be pretty sweet,
like look at the death moon comment
section to be used.
Just die of heart attacks and then other
people would just go raping and
pillaging and murdering.
That would be a bunch of different
things would happen.
It would be people that would live like
just savages.
They would just commit all sorts of
incredible atrocities and steal and do
all kinds of other shit and then there'd
be people that would just become total
hippies.
Just have orgies and probably what
people want to trade route.
Imagine.
Really you think so?
Some people would probably be like nine
slash 11 times a million.
Just being sad and probably be so many
specials on tv about it.
Song religion would pick up.
Look motherfucker,
oh my God.
Figure out some passage in the Bible
that related to this and that they.
They figured out a way to to to,
to connect the two of them together.
God,
Dan,
that would be incredible.
That would be the.
That's.
That's so possible.
That's happened.
It's happened in other solar systems.
I'm sure it's happened here.
You know,
it can happen in our lifetime.
That would be fucking bonkers,
man.
If we saw like it was 10 years away,
like we have a real issue,
would they even tell us there would be
rumors on the Internet?
I don't think they would tell us.
I don't think anybody was talking about
it.
What are the questions?
We'll go to this bridge.
I think my cat just took a shit in there
so I might smell her last scratching.
But you're a cat man.
Anyway.
Hey,
mayhem.
Miller 12.
When you say Joe was being a Dick,
I'm telling you it's distracting to me
and it keeps me from able to do in this
podcast.
Well,
I asked him to not do it.
So you're being a dick.
I wasted my question.
And religious bullshit.
Marbles are not dead.
Wow.
The marvel world is still huge
apparently.
Okay.
Let's go with the questions.
Here were the best substitute for the
current monetary system.
This dude wants to know who the fuck
knows,
right?
You can't.
I don't think you can have shit out
there and the fucking numbers in
computers that can't.
It's got to represent something.
Right.
That's the problem with money is it
doesn't really represent anything,
you know,
kind of represents more ideas and
anything.
It's not like one piece of gold,
you know,
is $1 and you know,
and that piece of gold was sitting in an
account somewhere and you can go,
you know,
cashier,
$100,
billion for 100 pieces of gold,
you know,
the,
it has to mean something.
You can't have it.
Just all numbers in computers because
people will just can fuck you.
You know,
like you've been going through,
I don't know how much you want to talk
about this,
but you've been going through some
bullshit with the irs where they,
you know,
they audit you and fuck with you and go
into numbers and like storing numbers
and how much numbers did you put on this
and how many numbers went to that?
And politics to me
is it,
my brain does not care about any of that
shit,
but that's how I've always been like
that.
Anything that I'm forced to do almost,
I almost don't care about,
you know.
Yeah.
Well that's sort of one of the reasons
why,
you know,
people sort of become artistic in the
first place.
You know,
I think one of the reasons why people
would call artistic is because you know,
you're,
you're
fighting against a bunch of shit you
don't like and you,
you go against the grain and you wind up
doing something that's totally
unconventional,
you know,
that's how people come and positions and
comedians and artists and stuff on the
side street path.
Yeah.
That's why it's so weird when like a
comedian enters into the world of
politics or something like that.
Like Al Franken.
Franken.
Yeah.
That's strange.
But that dude is like a serious
historian,
you know,
like that seems like it's sort of like a
project for him.
Like he really knows a lot of shit.
What about our kids?
I don't know.
What about our kids,
man?
What the fuck is going to happen?
What is going to happen?
No one knows,
man.
It's a strange world we live in.
It's a strange world.
That's the weirdest thing.
When you have kids,
you start wondering like,
how is this little person going to be
survive?
How they're gonna?
How are they going to be happy?
This crazy world and it gets nuttier and
nuttier and more goddamn earthquakes.
You know,
earthquake in Baja,
Mexico a couple of days.
Big One in Indonesia today.
I mean,
we have an earthquake's everywhere.
Dude.
It's getting really weird,
right?
Yeah.
It's like that.
Whoever opened up the treasure chest
from Indiana,
raiders of the lost
Ark,
you know,
it seems like some fucked up.
I haven't
weird how many people want to think that
it's because of like a US government
experiments that they're creating
earthquakes.
Like how nutty is that?
How it is.
That idea that the US government is
like,
I know that we need to do.
We need to just start causing
earthquakes everywhere.
Stupid.
It's hilarious though.
I mean,
it's hilarious how many people want to
believe nobody.
Shit like that.
When it comes to anything that's
happening,
they always want to find someone,
some human who's pulling the strings in
some gigantic diabolical scheme,
you know,
that a diabolical scheme with an
earthquake machine that just pointing at
it all these third world countries and
just fucking people up.
Like how hilarious is that?
What a,
what a,
a ass way to look at the world.
No,
I don't think that's what's happening.
I think that the earth is getting very
pissed off at us.
I think,
uh,
you know,
it's uh,
it's about time.
It's shaken us off.
No,
not really consciously,
but I think surely like this just
happens,
you know?
I mean,
look at what's going on in the moon.
There's creators all over the moon and
that nobody ever did anything bad on the
moon.
The moon is just a,
another little planet.
Shit happens.
Volcanoes erupt all over the world.
Earthquakes happen.
You know,
the topography of lifeless planets
constantly changes.
You know,
it's a.
is it,
is it
that we're having more earthquakes right
now or is just that we have twitter?
It could be that too.
Could be that.
Yeah.
I don't really know,
to be honest with you.
All I know is what I'm hearing that I'm
hearing about them more than I ever
heard about them before,
but I've not.
I've done looked at it at all.
I've done no research.
It does seem like we're hearing about it
way more than we ever heard about it
before.
Yeah.
We also more information pumped through
our eyeballs every day we've ever had in
our life.
Yeah.
Ten years ago I would only have found
out on my laser disk player.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
you would have found out 10 years ago if
it was really big newspaper people will
be paid below up my pager.
I found a page of the other day that I
used to have that my dog had bitten
into.
It's all fucked up.
And Jack Solaris.
Yeah.
I don't know man,
you know,
I got no answers to that.
I don't know if it's,
uh,
it's happening more or just more
information,
but there's definitely more information,
that's for sure.
That's 100 percent.
Whether or not the earthquakes are
happening more just seems like they are,
man.
Everybody's scared.
I'm about to lose a shitload of viewers.
Last starts when you know what,
we're about two hours anyway,
and that's why the way we like to end
it,
so we'll have one more topic.
Try to end it well,
and then we'll close it off.
Is it weird that you're so into
conspiracies,
but hate movies that have a twist
ending?
I hate movies that have a twist ending.
I love fucking movies with good twisty
ending that I didn't see comment.
What I don't like is when movies faked
me out and they say,
oh,
it was just a dream that drives me
bonkers and I'm not really into
conspiracies.
I'm into the real concern there.
Real things that people have conspired,
like Enron and you know,
I mean,
the problem with the whole term
conspiracy theory is you bring it up
like someone saw talks about conspiracy
theories and they bring it up.
All the automatically.
You any rational person,
any thinking person does not want to be
associated with conspiracy theories
because conspiracy theories make you
seem like a loon conspiracy theories the
way it's been labeled make,
make it seem like you're a silly
frivolous person that you believe in
ridiculous shit.
You know?
Yeah.
Well,
I think if you just tag it with the
conspiracy theory name,
but I think if you don't believe that
conspiracies,
but you think that's an interesting
approach to an idea or something like
like people that just think nine slash
11 was done by our own government and
they don't think anything else in the
and stuff like that.
That's a.
that's a sick way.
I think of anything.
You know,
you should never put all your eggs in
one basket type
that putting all your eggs in one basket
is a real problem.
We've talked about that before with our
friends,
with,
with certain subjects.
People love for there to be mysteries
that they can unsolved.
They love for there to be some hidden
information that they can unsolved,
whether it's about nine slash 11 or
about anything,
but the reality is,
you know,
unless you like really,
really,
really researched shit,
most people were just talking out their
ass when it comes to subjects and when
you do start researching shit,
you realize,
well you can't just blanketly discount
or discredit all conspiracy theories
just because it seems like a ridiculous
thing because a lot of them are fucking
real.
The Gulf of Tonkin,
the fucking operation.
Northwoods.
There's a lot of different shit that the
government has done and different
companies have done.
Cigarette companies have conspired to,
you know,
to,
to hide the facts about tobacco and to
make sure that people keep smoking them
and people were addicted.
This motherfucker's hook,
line and sinker with the cigarettes.
You're locked in.
How many smoke today?
Three.
Does that drive you bonkers?
Yeah,
because it's relaxing when I smoke a
cigarette,
but you don't worry about it.
Every time I smoked a cigarette and my,
my ellipse caught on fire,
then I would hate it.
Well,
what about like our friend that just
died,
you know,
stuff like that.
Thinking about your body just given out
on you and that doesn't drive me now.
Well I think it does to a point
definitely.
But I also think like,
shit,
I might have skin cancer right now.
I don't even know about it.
You know,
it's just either think about death all
the time.
Are you done?
So the red band approach is just to live
life capital might be a happy person,
but everybody else fight your wars and
do battle and then everyone else that
find out that everyone's stressed.
Do you ever
worry about your,
your think rather about not worried,
but do you ever consider your position
in this world or do you just try to just
live?
I don't think about anything like that
at all.
Don't think about.
I think about my happiness and that
that's pretty much what I think about
making sure that I am.
I'm happy and people are happy around
me.
I just wind to be happy person and I
want my friends to be happy,
but I do it.
Do I care about any thing else about
like fucking or anything like
that?
I try not to.
So when the storm troopers come,
you're just going to pack a bag and run
to the hills.
Fuck yeah.
Give a fuck about borders.
They grow in joke.
It's interesting because people can,
you know,
you can criticize that.
You can say that's apathy,
you know,
like this discussion that we had on the
board,
but I don't think that they're right.
I don't think they're right.
I think at a certain point in time it is
a foolish notion to try to control a
corrupt system.
It's a foolish notion.
It really is.
I could see both sides of it.
I could see people saying,
well,
if everybody thought that way,
there'd be no government.
It'd be,
oh,
this is bullshit.
You know,
you have to fucking stand up.
I could see that argument,
but I could also see her respond.
I see your argument.
I think you're right.
You know,
like a lot of people are already has
that same argument.
He says,
why do I care?
It's not gonna affect me.
Why do I care?
And in a certain way it really doesn't,
but in a certain way it does like social
things,
like you know,
Obama not going after the medical
marijuana.
That's,
that makes a big difference to me.
You know,
that's big to me.
Real estate issues like legalizing
medical marijuana in the state of
California,
that's something worth fucking voting
for.
That was a huge thing.
That's real.
That's a real issue that got resolved
and it changed a lot of people's lives
and it changed the whole climate of
California.
People are way more relaxed.
People are way chiller,
you know,
the access to weed is through the roof.
It's,
there's never been more access to in
this country ever than right now.
That's a real issue that was resolved by
voting.
So it's almost like state voting,
voting on state issues like that where
you can actually pick the issue.
Like that's real shit.
That's real.
Local politics seem to be real,
you know,
this is the reason why California is so
in depth.
We got an actor to be the governor.
You know,
we went with a dude that seemed like,
you know,
it was a no nonsense and we took this
fucking dude.
We was an action film star and we made
him the governor and Shit.
Just hit the fan,
hit the fan running.
You know,
it's fascinating,
you know,
because politics are local level seem to
be real.
But politics on a national levels.
Yeah,
it's not,
it doesn't seem very fucking real.
The end.
That's the end of this podcast
gentlemen.
Brian's good for two hours.
He starts fading.
It needs a,
he needs his coffee in a binky.
So thank you very much for tuning in,
ladies and gentlemen.
And uh,
don't you worry about me and Brian and
our argument.
I love this little fucker and he loves
me too,
which is just trying to make sure that
the,
um,
the podcast goes,
well,
that's all it is.
There's no hate.
We've been friends for ages,
a thank you for everything.
We will see you guys next week.
I got to go to Abu Dhabi this week for
the UFC.
That shit's gonna be crazy.
I never been to the United Arab Emirates
before,
but she'd be fascinating.
I'll have some pictures and for sure
I'll have some stories.
Definitely.
And I'll see you bitches next week.
So,
uh,
thank you very much for tuning in.
Follow us on twitter.
Brian only has a few thousand twitter
followers and he's very,
very upset about that.
He's a red band,
Reb,
b a n and uh,
he's very upset about your twitter.
Okay.
How many Ab right now?
Actually,
I just got like 100 recent.
I don't know if it's because of the DVD
or what.
Oh,
is it on the DVD as well?
Well,
my website's on the DVD or my name right
there you go.
But shows,
maybe it is because of that.
So right now Brian is a,
let's see,
I think it's like 1500.
I think I just went today.
I'm so close to 100,
$3,000.
Oh so close like 65 away.
It's hard to get a new twitter
followers,
you know,
it's like,
I don't know exactly what.
You got to mention it everywhere and
you've got to tweet a lot of interesting
shit.
But once you do,
man,
it's so important,
like for prefer promoting gigs and for
letting people know like shit,
you're doing like,
Hey,
I'm going to be in this town like this.
The best way for people to find out what
you're doing,
you know,
there's no better way to promote things,
and who knows what the next stage of
that is,
easily consumable,
easily consumed.
But Ladies and gentlemen,
this is easily consumable.
I hope you enjoy this.
This is the end of this week's Ustream
podcast,
and we will see you next week.
Thank you.
Love you.
Bye.